WE HAVE TWO BILLS ON CONSENT
ITEMS NUMBER TWO AND ITEM NUMBER
THREE WE ALSO HAVE.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE IS BEING HELD A
FOR A FUTURE HEARING AND SO --
WHAT WE'LL DO IS WE'LL BEGIN AS
A SUB COMMITTEE?
SINCE -- WE
DO NOT YET HAVE A QUORUM.
SO WHAT AND DO HIS ACTUALLY
SENATOR RAZA IN YOUR HERE.
SO I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND HAVE
YOU COME UP.
AND PRESENTE ITEM NUMBER ONE SB --
TWENTY NINE AND THANK YOU AND
WELCOME.
RELATIONS FOR CARE.
I GUESS IS YOUR FIRST COMMITTEE
PRESENTATION S. FIRST COMMITTEE
PRESENTATION IN.
THE UPPER PART OF FIRST BILL FOR
OUR HEARING THANK YOU.
I'M GLAD OR SORRY WE'RE OFF --
TO OF UP TO A REALLY GOOD BILL
THE COMMITTEE I APPRECIATE THIS
AN ENORMOUS AN IMPORTANT
OPPORTUNITY --
THE FEDERAL.
LAW FEDERAL CARE AFFORDABLE CARE
ACT THAT LED TO TENS OF MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE GETTING ACCESS TO
HEALTH INSURANCE.
SAYS THE FOLLOWING IF AN
INDIVIDUAL IS NOT A CITIZEN OR
AN ALIEN LAWFULLY PRESENT THE
INDIVIDUAL SHALL NOT BE TREATED
AS A QUALIFIED INDIVIDUAL.
AND MAY NOT BE COVERED UNDER
QUALIFIED HEALTH PLAN.
IN THE INDIVIDUAL MARKET THAT IS
OFFERED THROUGH THE EXCHANGE IN
OTHER WORDS FEDERAL LAW
EXPLICITLY AN UNJUSTLY EXCLUDES
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS FROM
RECEIVING HEALTH CARE THROUGH
MEDICAL.
AND FROM SELECTING THE HEALTH
PLAN OR PARTICIPATING IN COVERED
CALIFORNIA.
I DO NOT EVEN HAVE THE RIGHT TO
BUY HEALTH CARE COVERAGE IN THE
EXCHANGE THIS INCLUDES
INDIVIDUALS LIKE DACA RECIPIENTS
AND THE TPS RECIPIENTS WHO HAVE
BEEN HERE FOR DECADES.
SO AS A RESULT.
ON ONE AND A HALF OVER A MILLION
ON DOCTOR ADULTS ARE STILL LEFT
WITHOUT COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH
CARE.
THEY CAN'T EVEN GET PREVENTATIVE
CARE FOR ASTHMA OR RESPIRATORY
PROBLEMS OR DIABETES THEY RELY
ON EMERGENCY ROOMS THEY RELY ON
LAST MINUTE CARE.
THAT IS NO WAY TO TREAT PEOPLE
THE MAJORITY OF WOM HAVE WORKED
FOR DECADES RAISED FAMILIES AND
PARENTS.
PAID THEIR SHARE IN TAXES ALMOST
TWO THIRDS OF UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS HAVE LIVED IN THE
U. S. FOR MORE THAN TEN YEARS.
SO UNDOCUMENTED PARENT OR
GRANDPARENT CAN TAKE THEIR CHILD
OR GRANDCHILD TO SEE A DOCTOR
WHEN THEY ARE SICK BUT THE
PARENT OR GRANDPARENT CANNOT DO
THE SAME FOR THEMSELVES.
WE VIOLATE THE COMMON GOOD TO
LEAVE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT TREATMENT
FOR PREVENTABLE AILMENT SO SB
TWENTY NINE WILL REMOVE THE AGE
LIMIT FOR MEDI AL ELIGIBILITY.
DUE TO IMMIGRATION STATUS AND TO
PROVIDE MEDI CAL BENEFITS TO LOW
INCOME UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS WHOSE
INCOMES ARE AT OR BELOW 110038%
OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
NEARLY HALF OF UNDOCUMENTED IT
SIS CHILDREN MOST OF TEM --
ARE CITIZENS OR LAWFUL PERMANENT
RESIDENCE THIS REALITY HAS
TREMENDOUS HEALTH AND ECONOMIC
IMPACTS ON FAMILIES AND OUR
STATE.
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANTS ARE 34% OF
THE WORK FORCE TWICE THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE.
ONLY 121% OF NON CITIZENS HAVE
EMPLOYER SPONSORED HEALTH
INSURANCE SO THEY WORK BUT IT'S
NOT PROVIDED BY AN EMPLOYER
COMPARED. 268% OF CITIZENS WHOSE
EMPLOYER PROVIDES THE HEALTH
CARE I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
GOVERNOR NEW SOME FOR TAKING A
STEP. TO EXPAND MEDI CAL
ELIGIBILITY I BELIEVE THAT WE
ALL SHARE THE SAME DESIRE TO
PROVIDE UNIVERSAL HEALTH CARE TO
ALL CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
HERE THEY WERE BORN.
I AM CONFIDENT WE CAN REACH
UNIVERSAL HEALTHCARE AND AS WE
TWENTY NINE IS A BIG STEP
TOWARDS OUR GOAL.
HEALTHCARE IS A HUMAN RIGHT ALL
CALIFORNIANS SHOULD HAVE ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE.
OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM WORKS
BETTER AND IS MORE EFFICIENT
WHEN ALL CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
HAVE ACCESS TO A COMPREHENSIVE
HEALTH CARE.
CALIFORNIA MUST CONTINUE TO
CHAMPION SMART POLICIES THE
SUPPORT THE HEALTH OF OUR ENTIRE
COMMUNITY IS B. TWENTY NINE
BILLS ON OUR PROGRESS TOWARD
COME.
COME COVERING THE REMAINING
UNINSURED AND IS THE BUILDING
BLOCK TO BREEZE TO ACHIEVE
UNIVERSAL HEALTH CARE.
WE ARE ALREADY PAYING FOR PEOPLE
WHO HAVE TO RESORT TO EMERGENCY
ROOM CARE THERE WILL BE COST
SAVINGS FROM ALLOWING PEOPLE TO
ACCESS PREVENTATIVE CARE.
I KNOW THAT ALL OF US HAVE OUR
OWN PERSONAL STORIES I'LL BE THE
NOT HAVING HAD ACCESS TO HEALTH
INSURANCE OR WE KNOW OF SOMEONE
THAT IS UNINSURED WITHOUT ACCESS.
AS A MIGRANT FARM WORKER MYSELF
WELL WE WORKED HARD TO PUT FOOD
ON OTHER PEOPLE'S TABLES.
WE DID NOT HAVE HEALTH INSURANCE
AND AS A AN INFANT BROTHER IN MY
FAMILY WHO BECAME ILL.
LET'S KEEP OUR GOAL OF UNIVERSAL
COVERAGE AT THE TOP OF OUR LIST
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
US UNDER RAZA WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT WE ASK THAT FOR THE
TESTIMONY IF WE CAN --
TRY TO KEEP IT THEN SIX MINUTES
SO HOW MANY WITNESSES ARE THERE.
THREE OKAY SO TWO MINUTES A
PIECE -- THE
WELCOME AND PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF AND THE INTERIOR
TESTIMONY THANK YOU.
HI AM.
HI MY NAME IS LILLIAN SERRANO
AND I LIVE IN THE CITY OF
ESCONDIDO AND SAMUEL COUNTY --
MY HUSBAND WANTED TO BE HERE
TODAY BUT HE WAS UNABLE TO MAKE
IT.
HE ASKED ME TO SHARE WITH ALL OF
YOU.
A VERY IMPORTANT STORY FOR HIM
THE STORY OF HIS MOTHER.
SONYA HANOVER ABOUT I'M PHYLLIS
MY MOTHER IN LAW.
LAST SEPTEMBER MY FAMILY AND I
SUFFER THE LOSS OF MY MOTHER IN
LAW AFTER MONTHS OF TRYING
EVERYTHING AVAILABLE TO US TO
GET HER MEDICAL.
MEDICAL CARE.
MY MOTHER IN LAW WAS
UNDOCUMENTED AN UNINSURED AS
MANY IN OUR STATE.
THE NEW HANOVER Là ARRIVE IN A
SCHOOL IN THE THE OVER TWENTY
YEARS SEVERAL.
CIPOLLA LIFE THERE WITH EIGHT
KIDS INCLUDING MY HUSBAND WAS
ABOUT TO GRADUATE WITH A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE FROM COST THE
SAN MARCOS.
IN A WAY WHAT TOOK CARE OF HER
KIDS HER GRANDCHILDREN AND EVEN
COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
SHE WAS A COMMUNITY LEADER WHO
WOULD ALWAYS STRUCK TO
DEMONSTRATIONS AND LOCAL
HEARINGS.
OVER A YEAR AGO SHE STARTED
SUFFERING FROM A STRONG
ABDOMINAL PAIN.
SO WE TOOK HER TO THE COMMUNITY
CLINIC.
NONE OF US COULD HAVE IMAGINED
THAT THE PARTS THE LADY.
THAT WHAT WAS SEEM LIKE A
STOMACH PAIN WILL BECOME GALL
BLADDER CANCER.
IT WAS A LONG PROCESS JUST TO
GET CLOSE TO DIAGNOSIS BECAUSE
COMMUNITY CLINICS ARE NOT THE
SAME FOR THESE CASES.
WE NEED A SPECIALIST AND MORE
TEST FOR THE CLINIC GET AN OFFER.
WE TRIED DIFFERENT PLACES BUT
MOST DON'T TAKE CARE.
OF MOVES ON TAKE PEOPLE WITHOUT
INSURANCE THE COSTS ARE TOO HIGH.
OR THE WAIT TIME FOR TOO LONG.
BUT YOU HAD A LIVER KEPT COMING
IN AND OUT OF THE LOCAL
EMERGENCY ROOM.
IT WAS ONLY AFTER SHE WENT TO
THE ER AND UC'S FUND IT WILL
MEDICAL CENTER.
THAT SHE WAS ABLE TO GET PROPER
ASSESSMENT.
AT THAT POINT THE DOCTOR WAS
ABLE TO COME FROM THE HEART
TRUTH.
THE SHE HAD FINAL STAGE CALLED
BLADDER CANCER.
THE DOCTOR THINKS THAT THE
CANCER HAD ALREADY BEEN
SPREADING OVER FOR OVER FIVE
YEARS.
THIS WHOLE LAUNCH IWIN WITHOUT
SEEING A DOCTOR.
EXPLAIN THAT EARLY SYMPTOMS
COULD HAVE BEEN CONFUSED FOR
FACT THAT JUST THE PROBLEMS.
THE NATIONAL WEBER HAD NEVER
VISIT A DOCTOR BECAUSE HE WAS
OUT OF HER BUDGET.
ONCE SHE FIVE HAD FINAL STAGE
CANCER THERE WAS NOTHING WE
COULD DO ANYMORE. FOR YOU HAND
OVER PASSED AWAY SURROUNDED BUT
ALL HER KIDS AND GRANDKIDS ON
HER HOSPITAL BED AFTER TWO WEEKS
OF FINALLY RECEIVING MEDICAL
TREATMENT.
THOSE WERE THE LONG AND PAINFUL
WEEKS FOR MYFAMILY AND I THE
WOMAN WHO HAD TAKING CARE OF ALL
OF US INCLUDING ME.
QUITE EVEN SURE BLOOD WITH HER.
WAS DYING IN A HOSPITAL BED AND
THERE WAS NOTHING WE COULD DO.
WE ALL KEPT ASKING OURSELVES
WHAT SHE COULD HAVE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO TO CROWN OR
REGULAR DOCTOR VISITS.
WHAT IS SHE WAS NOT UNDOCUMENTED?
WHAT IS SHE WAS ABLE TO ACCESS
HEALTH CARE?
ACCESS TO HEALTHCARE IS A MATTER
OF LIFE AND DEATH.
GETTING PROPER MEDICAL CARE
EARLY COULD HAVE PREVENTED THE
LOSS OF THE NATIONAL REVERSE.
A COMMUNITY LEADER AND THE CITY
OF A SCHOOL IN THE LOW.
WHO WAS THE HEART OF OUR MY
FAMILY?
WHO WOULD I NEED TO DO TO SEE
HER SO WE WOULDN'T HAVE TO SEE
HER SUFFER WITHOUT A WAY OF
PREVENTING OR STOPPED HER PAIN?
WHO WOULDN'T BE LEFT WITH THE
OWN PAY MEDICAL BILLS AND NOW WE
HAVE STRUGGLING TO PAY?
MY FAMILY AND I ADVOCATE ARE
ADVOCATES FOR HEALTH FOR ALL
ADULTS BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT
ANYONE ELSE TO GO THROUGH THE
EXPERIENCE THAT WE JUST WENT
THROUGH.
WE BELIEVE THAT NO ONE SHOULD
HAVE TO SUFFER OR DIE.
FROM A TREATABLE CONDITION NO
MATTER WHERE THEY WERE POINT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I ACTUALLY WENT TAKE A
MOMENT TO CALL THE ROLL SINCE WE
HAVE A QUORUM A SECRETARY CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PAN.
AND IS HERE STONE.
STONE IS HERE DRAGO.
DURAZO'S HERE GROW.
HER TADO.
HER TOES HERE LEYVA.
MITCHELL MONNING RUBIO.
RUBIO IS HERE.
THE FORM OF A QUORUM THANK YOU --
YOU HAVE ABOUT TWO AND A HALF
MINUTES LEFT SO OVER THE
REMAINING SPEAKERS WELCOME
ABSOLUTELY.
A GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS DEEPENING ACNE SHOW WITH
THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER WE ARE PROUD CO SPONSOR
OF SB TWENTY NINE TO EXTEND MEDI
CAL.
I'M TO ALL INCOME ELIGIBLE
RESIDENTS REGARDLESS OF THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS --
ONE INTO CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA
HAS AN IMMIGRANT HAS AN
IMMIGRANT PARENT AND ONE IN SIX
CHILDREN HAS AND UNDOCUMENTED
PARENTS.
AND A YOU JUST HEARD THESE
PARENTS ALONG WITH OLDER
SIBLINGS AND GRANDPARENTS
CONTINUE BE SYSTEMATICALLY
EXCLUDED FROM ACCESSING CRITICAL
HEALTHCARE SERVICES.
LILIAN STORY AS WELL COUNTLESS
OTHERS SHOWS THAT THE PAINFUL
REALITY THAT FAMILY SEPARATION
IS NOT JUST THE RESULT OF WALLS
AND BANDS THAT FAMILY SEPARATION
CAN ALSO RESULT.
FROM DEEP INEQUITIES IN OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM IS BETWEEN AND
THEIR FAMILIES AND HEALTHCARE
ACCESS AND YET AND WEREN'T
COMMUNITIES LIVED WITH THIS FEAR --
WE RECENTLY CONDUCTED A STUDY
WHICH FOUND HIGH IN THE LIVES OF
ANXIETY AND TRAUMA ACROSS THE
STATE AND IMMIGRANT FAMILIES --
SINCE NOVEMBER OF TWENTY SIXTEEN
AND THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT
URGENTLY NEED PREVENTIVE HEALTH
CARE AND MENTAL HEALTH CARE.
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS
CONTRIBUTE THREE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS.
EVERY SINGLE YEAR AND STATE AND
LOCAL TAXES AND MAKE UP ONE
TENTH OF OUR STATE'S WORK FORCE
WHEN AND UNDOCUMENTED ADULT GETS
INJURED ON THE JOB THEY HAVE A
FEW OPTIONS TO ACCESS CARE FOR
INJURIES AND OFTENTIMES THE
RESULT IS PERMANENT DISABILITY
OR DEATH.
NOW MORE THAN EVER CALIFORNIA'S
LEADERSHIP AND CARING.
FOR AN UPHOLDING THE DIGNITY OF
OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL AND WE HAVE
THE POLITICAL WILL AND RESOURCES
TO MAKE IT HAPPEN TOGETHER AND
FOR THESE REASONS WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY NINE
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JESSICA MORAN I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA I'M
PROUD TO BE HERE AS A SPONSOR
IMPELLED SUPPORTER OF SB TWENTY
NINE WHICH EXPAND MEDI CAL
ELIGIBILITY TO ALL ADULTS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS.
A SPENDING MEDICAL TO ALL LOW
INCOME ELIGIBLE ADULTS
REGARDLESS IMMIGRATION STATUS
WOULD --
ALLOW US TO HAVE ONE POINT ONE
FIVE MILLION ADULTS IN ROLE BY
TWENTY TWENTY WHICH WOULD
DECREASE CALIFORNIA'S UNINSURED
RATE BY A QUARTER.
LOW INCOME UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS ARE OFTEN OFFERED
DOBBY'S INSURANCES SIMILAR TO
MANY LAWFULLY PRESENT LOW INCOME
WORKERS HOWEVER 90% OF
UNDOCUMENTED LOW INCOME WORKERS
DO NOT HAVE HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPARED TO ONLY 10% OTHER
LAWFULLY PRESENT COUNTERPARTS.
CURRENTLY THEY ARE OFFERED
RESTRICTED SCOPE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL BUT THAT ONLY COVERS
EMERGENCIES IT'S STABILIZE THE
PATIENT BUT ISN'T TREAT WHAT
MIGHT BE A CHRONIC CONDITION.
THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO PRIME
PERMIT --
PRIMARY CARE DOCTORS PREVENTIVE
SERVICES OR EVEN PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS.
MOST OF THE TIME THEY ARE
TALKING GO WITHOUT CARE THE
ELEMENTS.
AND DEPENDING ON WHERE THEY LIVE
THEY MIGHT HAVE ACCESS TO COUNTY
BASED --
HEALTH PROGRAMS BUT IN MANY
RURAL AREAS THOSE SEEKING THAT'S
ARE UNAVAILABLE.
NOT HAVING US ACCESS TO
HEALTHCARE IT MEANS THAT THE
ONLY ONE SICKNESS OR INJURY AWAY
FROM FINANCIAL CALAMITY DUE TO
MOUNTING MEDICAL BILLS AND HIGH
MEDICAL COSTS.
BY PASSING SB TWENTY NINE WE CAN
ENSURE THAT EVERYONE IN OUR
STATE HAS ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
WHEN THEY NEED IT REGARDLESS OF
THE IMMIGRATION STATUS FOR THESE
REASONS WE ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND IN THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR COURAGE IN COMING
YEAR TRAINS STORY AND NOW THEY
CAN BE DIFFICULT THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES SUPPORT IF YOU
CAN LIVE THE MICROPHONE --
NAME ORGANIZATION AND I GUESS AT
THIS POINT YOUR POSITION SHOULD
BE ISN'T SUPPORT IF YOU'RE AT
THE MICROPHONE RIGHT NOW.
SO WE CAN LINE UP WELCOME.
SON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
ARE TOM RENT FREE WITH THE
COUNTY BE ABLE HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA --
WE FULLY SUPPORT SB TWENTY NINE
INTRODUCING THIS BILL WHICH WILL
SAVE LIVES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
CALIBAN HERE BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING OVER FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND PHYSICIANS AND
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
BETSEY ARMSTRONG ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
ON A HOUSE ABOUT ON BEHALF OF
UNITED WAYS OF CALIFORNIA THE
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP IN STRONG SUPPORT.
YOU.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GABRIELLE THE START WITH THE
NATIONAL IMMIGRATION LAW CENTER
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
HI JENNA BERNARD BEAR WITH ME
FOR ME OF WHAT THAT IN THE IN
THE COALITION FOR MAKING JUSTICE.
HELLO EVERYONE THE ANYMORE DEAL
WITH THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
YOUTH JUSTICE ALLIANCE AND I AM
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR
HEALTH FOR ALL.
BUT ALSO --
AND I AM ALSO HERE TO UPLIFT
UNDOCUMENTED ELDERS ARE WE VALUE
THE LIVES OF OUR ELDERS AND ARE
COMMITTED TO CARING FOR ALL OUR
ELDERS FIRST THANK YOU THANK YOU
YEAH WHEN A TAKING.
ADDITIONAL TESTS MAY NOT LIKE
THE PLACENTA HOTTEST WITH A DOCU
ELDERS WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF HEALTH FOR ALL IN ONE IS
UNDER THE LIVES OF OUR IN DOCU
OUT ELDERS THAT ARE MOST HUMBLE.
OUR MOST VULNERABLE AND IN THE
MOST LEAD THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER SERRA FLOCKS
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU --
MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY IN SUPPORT HE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS MEGAN
SUPERS ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTH PLUS ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARK MENDOZA
WITH THIS YEAR YOU CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT. HUNDRED YEARS ON
BEHALF THE CHILD ABUSE
PREVENTION CENTER ON SUPPORT.
JENNIFER SANTOS WITH CALIFORNIA
FROM RESEARCH SIX RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
MARIA IS A FRIEND OF FLOORS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE IN SUPPORT.
JENNIFER ALI WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS IN
SUPPORT.
BARBARA GLAZER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT.
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
HOSPITALS AND HEALTH SYSTEMS
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
VANESSA KICKING ON BEHALF OF
WINTERS FAMILY PARTNERSHIP IN
CALIFORNIA LATINAS REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE HERE IN SUPPORT.
WHERE IS THE INVOLVED WITH THE
SET NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS AND THE DAUGHTER
OF IMMIGRANTS IN BROAD SUPPORT?
DARIA MCGREW ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. TWO MEN REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT YOU.
TAYLOR JACKSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING OVER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND REGISTERED NURSES
STATEWIDE IN SUPPORT.
LINDA TERRACE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
GET THE MOST FOR THE LOCAL
HEALTH PLANS A CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
TRACY PATTERSON CALIFORNIA FOOD
POLICY ADVOCATES IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT YOU.
CATHERINE AGREED ON ON BEHALF OF
FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
MORE COVER WITH SMALL BUSINESS
MAJORITY IN SUPPORT.
MARIA MELLOW WITH THE LOS
ANGELES LGBT CENTER STRONG
SUPPORT IN UP LIFTING THE THE
EXPERIENCE OF LGBT UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOSEPHINE
FIGARO ON BEHALF OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER GOT A LOT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DURING CAMPBELL ON BEHALF OF LA
KAREN SUPPORT.
I ENGRAM ACLU OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT HE SURVEY CASTEEL BEHALF
OF ESSENTIAL ACCESS HEALTH IN
SUPPORT.
ALISON RAINY WITH BLUE SHIELD OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LEE LOW WHAT THE SOUTHEAST ASIA
RESOURCE ACTION CENTER AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GABRIELLE BARBOSA WITH THE
ALLIANCE FOR BETTER COMMUNITY IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
ALI TO ROBBIE WITH THE SENATOR
MEGA RIGHTS CONSORTIUM AND WHO
I'VE LIVED IN THIS COUNTRY FOR
TWENTY THREE YEARS UNDOCUMENTED.
AND I FOR TO SUPPORT THIS THANK
YOU.
BUDGET SO ON BEHALF OF ST JOHN'S
WELL CHILD AND FAMILY CENTER
INSTRUCTS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KAREN BY AND NOW WE HAVE OF THE
ST YOU EVER GET RIGHTS
CONSORTIUM AND STRONG SUPPORT.
JONATHAN SO LOS ON A LOT OF
TRIMMING RIGHTS COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT YOU.
ABBY GOVERNMENTS WITH THE LATINO
COLLISION FOR HOW THE CALIFORNIA
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JENNY FLORES HARO MYSTICAL IN
THE CAN A COMMUNITY ORGANIZING
PROJECT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
PHYLLIS AND I ONE SIDED WITH
TOWARD LEGAL CENTER HERE FOR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
LOOK AT THE ACROSS OUR BUILDINGS
LEGAL CENTER INLAND EMPIRE
COACHELLA VALLEY THIS IS A
PICTURE OF MY UNCLE.
HE JUST WE JUST BURIED HIM TWO
WEEKS AGO.
ARE YOU DON'T HAVE ACCESS ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE AND WE'RE FULLY
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
FUND THANK YOU.
MY SYMPATHIES MEN NUMBER READ
MUDDY YEAH GORDANA URINE GO TO
PRESENT THEN THOUGH I DON'T SEE
ANY OTHER THE BADLEES.
GET YOUR **** THE NASCO I. A USE
IT AT THE END SOON MEDICA GONNA
FIFTH MESSAGE THANK YOU.
THE NUMBER S. MIGHTIEST BELOW
SEVEN GOING TO PRESENT ON THAT
THOUGH THEY THEY HAVE A LAND
FILL.
HERE STATEMENT WAS THAT IT KEPT
ASIDE I HAVE LIBERAL BY SO THEY
LAW SENIOR SPREAD OUT YOU SEE AN
AD IN THE IN THE OLD BUT I CAN
SEE AN AD IN THE IN THAT THOUGH
THE GLASS YES.
BASIS.
HI MY NAME IS MICHAEL BUT I HAS
AN IBM WITH --
TOLD BUILDINGS LEGAL CENTER AND
I SUPPORT --
KAELIN FOR ON THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS BECOMING CURRENTS
THAT COME FROM TOLD IT FROM
CERTAIN TO MEDINA AND AYE AYES
TO I ASK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
HE SEES THE FUTURE OF BY MULDER
THAT SHE DIES BECAUSE CONSERVE
BECAUSE SHE DIDN'T HAVE.
HEALTHCARE AND THAT'S WHAT I CAN
I AM HERE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
YEAH MARTY WITH SIRENS SERVICES
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS IN EDUCATION
NETWORK IN SAN JOSE AND FRESNO
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ALLEY SO SERVICE AND
I'M A COMMUNITY MEMBER OF SOME
OF SEVEN I WORKING WITH SITE
INVOLUNTARY FOR LIKE NINE YEARS
AND I WOULD LIKE DO YOU GUYS
SUPPORT HELP FOR ALL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MARGARITA SUNDAY OFF FROM THE BY
NATIONAL CENTER FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE INDIGENOUS
WHAT HOW CAN YOU COMMUNITY AND
TRANSPORT.
THANK YOU.
MINIMUM MOTORS ON JUST A REGULAR
LEFT WITH ONLY ONE TIME BECAUSE
YOU FOR NOW.
YEARS AGO LIVE AND SOCIAL
DECIDED.
HE A BINGO ARM.
AS YOU CAN LOOK ON ME I EITHER
ON THE YOU'LL BE ABLE ON PLACES
OFFICIALS WILL GIVE YOU MY LOOK
I THE BUT THIS WILL RESULT IN
AND SO WILL MEDICAL.
THERE ARE CLASSES.
IN COMMERCE WITH APPLE OF LOS
ANGELES AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
NAME'S TONYA GOING ON WITH THE
INLAND COALITION FOR IMMIGRANT
JUSTICE I'M HERE TO ALSO
SPEAKING HAVE MY PARENTS WHO
WOULD BENEFIT FROM THIS --
BILL --
THEY'RE BOTH HERE FOR OVER TWO
DOCUMENT THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO TO HEALTH CARE SO --
I'M HERE TO SPEAK FOR THEM
BECAUSE BECAUSE OF THEM I AM
HERE.
I'M HOLDING MY MASTER'S DEGREE
AND I AM CONTINUING THE DREAM
FOR THEM [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND NANCY WELL THE VENUS FROM
THE A IN THE COALITION OF
IMMIGRANT JUSTICE AND I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF ALL THE
UNDOCUMENTED ELDERS WHO CONTINUE
TO STRUGGLE WITHOUT HEALTH CARE.
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LIZ THAT MENDOZA WITH INLAND
COALITION FOR IMMIGRANT JUSTICE
ALSO HERE WITH A MANY OF OUR
PARTNER CITY TO SUPPORT HEALTH
FOR ALL FOUR ON ARE UNDOCUMENTED
ELDERS MANY OF THEM CAN JOIN US
TODAY --
ACTUALLY ONE PARTICULAR FAMILY
CANCELED BECAUSE THEIR ELDER LEE --
THEIR GRANDMA IS IN THE HOSPITAL --
GETTING CARE AT THIS MOMENT SO
THEY COULDN'T JOIN US AND WE
KNOW THAT THEIR NORMALLY THE
FOLKS THAT PROVIDE FOR US AND
CARE FOR US.
AND AND CAN ALWAYS JOIN AS A
LOBBY VISITS BUT WE HOPE THAT WE
COME IN STRONG IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE --
ONCE WE WE GO BACK HOME THANK
YOU FOR THE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI I'M LESLIE TIME WITH ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE LOS
ANGELES AND ORANGE STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS BENJAMIN SHALL
I AM WITH UPLIFT LOS ANGELES.
I AM UNDOCUMENTED AND I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF MYSELF AND MY
SINGLE MOTHER AND MY THREE
BROTHERS --
FOOT TO EXPAND MEDI CAL TO COVER
OUR FAMILY WE LIVED.
AND THE UNITED STATES FOR TWENTY
YEARS NEVER HAVING RELIABLE
HEALTH INSURANCE.
AND MY OLDEST BROTHER'S ACTION
ARE AT AND WE'RE STILL YOU KNOW
BECAUSE OF OUR OUR FAMILY INCOME
WE WE WE CANNOT.
QUALIFY FOR AFFORDABLE HEALTH
CARE -- I'M
HERE BECAUSE MY FAT MY MOTHER
AND MY BROTHERS INVESTED IN MY
OWN HEALTH.
AND I BELIEVE THAT WE CAN INVEST
IN OUR HEALTH.
TOGETHER THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CRYSTAL ROBLESS
WITH BECAUSE FROM SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY AND HERE SUPPORT FOR
HEALTHCARE FOR ALL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS STEPHANIE
RODRIGUEZ I'M HERE WITH BECAUSE
AND WE CARE FOR SUPPORT SB
TWENTY NINE THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS VERONICA HOURS HE
GOT WOULD BE CYNICAL BROUGHT ME
SO WITH THE LARGEST PROMOTED AS
NOBODY CALIFORNIA WITH MORE THAN
FIVE THOUSAND PROMOTED AS A WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME
SALINAS SANTA MARIA ON BEHALF OF
NEXT IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY NINE
THANK YOU.
VETERAN PALMER BEHALF OF CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
WE'RE NOT THAT THIS NUMBER AND
I'M AT THE NET.
NUMBER OF THE LOCAL MONEY THAT
YOU SAY BUT THE AND BIT EVEN
EVEN YOU KNOW THE LIST ON THE
CALIFORNIA APPLE YEAH.
THAT'S THE ADDRESSES.
WE WILL START WITH ME NUMBER
SEVENTEEN FORTIES SELECT ONE
OTHER SACRAMENTO IN ONE UP FOR
YOU --
YOU'RE REQUEST YES BASSES.
WHEN I STARTED WITH ME NUMBER A
CELL ON BACK IN DAY DOMINGO
THEY'VE GONE THAT'LL THEY FRESNO?
SO YEAH BUT SEE AND THEY YOU SO
YOU THAT CALL MONEY THAT YOU
EVEN GO UP FOR YANDLE
[inaudible]
THIS IS.
LET THE CELEBUZZ AMBER BOTTLE
CALIFORNIA HERE WITH THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS TO LEARN MORE HERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
HELLO ENERGY FOR SUPPORT --
HERE TO SUPPORT PEAVEY TWENTY
NINE I BELIEVE IT IS A
BIRTHRIGHT FOR EVERYONE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE REGARDLESS
OF WHERE YOU FROM OR WHERE YOU
COME -- ARMS
FULL SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS ROSE WONDER
BECAUSE MINE AND I'M FROM BY
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TULARE
COUNTY --
I'M HERE IS --
REPRESENTING CHIRLA I ALSO
SUPPORTER AS BE.
TWENTY NINE THANK YOU.
HELLO GOODBYE GOOD AFTERNOON --
MY NAME IS ANYTHING ELSE I AM
THE CENTRAL VALLEY ORGANIZER FOR
THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS CHIRLA WE'RE
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ONE REPRESENTS
REPRESENTING THE FIVE THOUSAND
PEDIATRICIANS AND SUB PEDIATRIC
SUB SPECIALISTS WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS RHONDA REESE --
A COMMUNITY LEADER OUT FRESNO
AND I'M A STRONG SUPPORTER OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THE NUMBER IS ONE MEDINA SIPPING
A DIFFERENT OF CALIFORNIA HE W.
[inaudible]
SB [inaudible] TWENTY NINE
CRISIS.
JUST EMILY RESEMBLES A COMMUNITY
LEADER FROM FRESNO CALIFORNIA
AND US A DOCTOR RECIPIENT AND
FROM IMMIGRANT HAVING IMMIGRANT
PARENTS I'M A FULL SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
THE NUMBER IS EIGHT MM CAN'T
BANGALA CAN FINALLY IS FULLY UP
FOR YOU [inaudible]
CRISIS.
ME NO MATTER MY AREA OF OUR
LIVES IF THEY GIVING WITH A
FRIEND ALSO THE LIMIT OF THE
MONEY THAT YOU FOR YOUR FOR
YOUNG ADULTS BUT IF YOU.
ACCESS.
ME NUMBER IS MAHDI ABED AND FIND
YOU SOMETHING OTHER ECONOMIC
CALIFORNIA REALLY IS THERE FOR
YOU [inaudible]
THE BEST.
SO YOU MIGHT AIR THE LATTER
BANGLA THAT KIND OF MONEY THE UP
OR DOWN WHEN THE STUDY WITH BAND
WHAT FOR YOUNGER [inaudible]
AXIS.
WHEN ASSEMBLY NUMBER CITY COME
INSIDE LITTLE SOCCER HISTORY
THAT THE LOCAL MONEY THAT THEY
WILL PUT YOU IN THE PROPOSED TO
SOON BUT?
ALAS I LOW BUT A PERSON US IN
THE COMMENT THAT WITH THAT.
BASIS.
MY NAME IS JOYCE GEORGE AND I AM
STRONGLY SUPPORT AN S. B. --
TWENTY NINE STRONGLY SUPPORTED.
THANK YOU S. CI YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MADELEINE MAXWELL WITH SEIU
YOU A TWO W. AND I'M STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
AARON BROOKS BOYD SACRAMENTO
COUNTY IN HOME SUPPORT SERVICES
HEALTH FOR ALL S. CI YOU AND I
AM IN VERY MUCH STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
BLANCA GO THEATERS ARE ON BEHALF
OF THE COMMUNITY CLINIC
CONSORTIUM OF CONTRA COSTA AND
SOLANO COUNTY AND FULL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
I LOOSELY WITH CAREER RESOURCE
CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT BECAUSE
MY PARENTS DESERVE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE AND SO THE ALL THE
OTHER AND TALKING TO PARENTS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DO YOU CHOI WITH THE CRANE
RESISTOR CENTER AND FULL SUPPORT.
RIGHT NUMBER LIST WELL A A PER
LOCAL MEDIA.
MANUAL THANK [inaudible]
CRISIS.
THE NUMBER IS MY IDEA OF A LEVEL
EVEN WHAT FOR YANDLE AT THE
LOCAL MONEY THAT PRODUCT IT
THOUGH THOSE.
S. SEVEN A PC IN KNIN MEDI CAL
GET ANNOYED OTHER SCREAMING
ASEAN BUT AT THE LAST BUT SOME.
WHICH OVER THE FIFTH
[inaudible]
THAT IS.
ALUMINUM IS ON A MOTORCADE ES
ACCU PARK WHERE [inaudible]
CLASSES.
HI I'M EVERADO GARCIA FRESNO CA.
IS MY IN COURT THIS DAY STOCKTON
CALIFORNIA THE LOCAL MONEY DARIA
LEVELS THE SAN JOAQUIN IF YOU
KNOW OF ANY SAYS HE ON POLITICAL
ME KINDA MORE IN A PRESS YES
SUPPORT THOMAS THE CHEST MAYBE
THIS [inaudible]
CRISIS.
HI MICHAEL CAN CHARGE BECAUSE
CAUSATION AS SENATE DISTRICT
TWENTY FOUR AND PARTS OF SENATOR
RUSSELL IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
LYDIA LOPEZ ON THAT ABOUT HOKUM
BUT YET THOUGH MYSTICAL.
IS THAT THE WHOLE SO READ ON
TELECOM OPEN WITHOUT A LOSS HAD
LOUIS GET ALSO LOOKED AT THE
LOOKS [inaudible]
ACCESS.
HELLO MY NAME IS STEPHANIE
LEVELS AND ON BEHALF OF ANY
COUNTING ON OLD GOVERNMENTAL AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
THIS MOVING OUT OF THIS MAY
NUMBER IS TO TEN I'M A GUY
THAT'S A PROMOTED AS HELLO THEY
CLINIC I'M LOOKING OUT FROM
METAL.
KIDDLE IS THIS A MEAL.
THE ONE THAT'S GIVING GOAL
GóMEZ THE PROPOSES YOUNG.
YOU CAN LOOK AT FOUR FIVE
ORDINALS ARE USING.
I KßT THE PURPLE TO JUMP BASS
A YEAH.
BARGAIN WITH THAT CAN'T THEY
STAND THIS IS IT SIGN YOUR IN
THE WIRELESS THEY WERE THE WHAT
THAT THE MIDDLE YEAH.
I IF THE PROPOSED HIS YOUNG.
OKAY FORGET NOT GET HIM A BIT
MORE AT THIS IS A FREE MAN
TALKING WITH A FAMILIAR.
YES YES.
US HISTORY.
THANK YOU ARE GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS AN ISLAND I'M AT THE
NEWS AND I AM FROM CLINIC I'M A
SINGLE METAL YOU KNOW SIGN
HILLIS AND I AM OUT WE HAD A
STRONG SUPPORTER.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ME NUMBER SOMEBODY ALONE YOU'LL
SO UNITED THAT ONLY THIRTY OTHER
LISTED IN THE SUN CAN LIST.
HE UP BUT I MEAN MANY BUT BUT
THE POINT IS THE PROPOSES YOUR
LIFE.
SEVENTEEN ELEVEN BUT I CABLE A
LITTLE BOTH ARE SOME OF THE
OBVIOUS WHAT I'M GOOD AT I NEED
YOU KNOW SOME OF THE OBVIOUS.
AND WE'LL DO NOT MAKE THIS EQUAL
LAW HE GONNA HE'S OF THE ELEMENT
THAT BACK UP WITH ANY YOU'LL SEE
THAT IT'S QUITE Là YOU THIS ARE
YET TO COME WHEN THE TWO THAT I
KNOW OF IT DOES NOT BILL DO YOU
HAVE.
BUT THE LIST OF THE PRESENT THAT
THIS WILL NOT CORD BLOOD MAYBE
GOT FIRED UP.
THANK WOULD NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION PLEASE THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S KENNY LAY I'M WITH
A SPIRE I'M ALSO GRADUATE
STUDENT WITHOUT MY A DOG THE
MENTORS AND HOLDERS I WOULDN'T
BE HERE TODAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS EMILY PARK ON BEHALF
OF ASIAN HEALTH SERVICES IN
OAKLAND IN STRONG SUPPORT ALSO
ON BEHALF OF A SPIRE IN SAN
FRANCISCO WHEN YOUR SON FROM AZ
A YOU YOU H. W. --
COMMUNITY THE VISION AND NINETY
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT IT STRONGLY
A WE'VE BEEN SEEING A LOT OF FOR
COMMUNITY THE DIE IN JUST
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE.
THE FULL COVERAGE SO PLEASE
PLEASE PASS THIS LAW IS B.
TWENTY NINE NINE AND I'M WAS
SOMEWHAT IN.
THANK YOU.
ALLOW ME NUMBER A LOUD ALREADY
YES EVN THOUGH THE SAN LEANDRO
CALIFORNIA.
E. MIMI CORPUSCULAR MAN'S
BOTANICAL PROMESA GET AWESOME UP
ALL YOUR BY LAWS IMMEDIATE AND
THIS BUT COMPANIONS SOME OF THE
MODELS BUT GET THEM IN THOSE
IMPAIR MAMMALS IN AS AS HE
DOUBLES UP FOR YOU.
THIS IS THE TEMAS KENNELS VAN.
YES YES BASIS.
THE NUMBER IS MEDIA GONZALEZ
EVEN GORKY APPLE YEAH AND THE
LIKE WE WOULD HAVE A THEY LOOK
THE HAVE A LOOK AT THE END OF
THE IRATE THESE ELABORATE
INFORMATICA FROM BEING A FIFTY
FIVE I THOUGHT THE V. AMERICA.
A YEAR LATER HOW THE FUNDING OF
THE FALLACY OF YOUTH THE COMMON
LAW HAVE A FABULOUS IF IT MORE.
RIGHT THE STATUS ARE FOR YOUR
LUCK [inaudible]
CORRECT THE HELLO MY NAME IS ON
JOHNNY MINOR HUNG FROM THE CITY
OF SANTA MARIA CALIFORNIA.
AND OF THE I'M CURRENTLY A GRAD
STUDENT AT UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA DAVIS --
I'VE SEEN THEM.
THE OUR COMMUNITY --
WITH GOING UNDERGROUND AND IN
THE SHADOWS AND HEALTH FOR
EVERYONE.
THANK YOU.
THAT'S BECAUSE I KNOW THAT IT'S
A UNITED HEALTHCARE WORKERS WAS
ALCHEMY ORGANIZED A STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CHRIS RESPONSIBLE CHAIR OF THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS AND OFFER A PRISONER
YOUTH ORGANIZATION THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM NETWORK
INSTRUCTS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HELLO WHEN I STARTED THIS NUMBER.
THIS CAR ROBERTA VOTERS HEARING
WILL BE MADE OF A SAKE A START
OF A NEW SYSTEM.
THE RADICAL MOST THOUGHT LOOKED
UP A SANDAL CVO RAIL CARILLO
MUCHO MORE TO BOOK A BOOK AND
WHY SUTTLE NORMAL SO YOU WITHOUT.
PHOTO OKAY --
BORDERS INCLUDING THE COMMON
DOES CONTAIN BUT BALLOT.
HE'LL DESTROY ISRAEL O'DONNELL
NOTING OF OFFENDERS FOR EXAMPLE
MALL OUTSIDE LIEU ENMITY COTTON.
IT MEDI CAL.
SAYS STUDY UNDER THEIR ME BETTER
IN THIS IS IT I YOLO UP DOES
ALLOW YOU THE HISTORIC HONEST
ORDERING SYSTEM.
DOI INDIA WELL YES A GOOD OF THE
LAND THAT WHICH I DON'T YES
THAT'S RIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TINA
DE I'M FORMATION HEALTH SERVICES
IN OAKLAND'S AND ALSO I'M TEN
TWENTY ONE WHAT THE SENATE.
TO NO I BOTTOM ALL REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS NORMA GONZALEZ FROM
BRAVE LITTLE AGING I SUPPORT A
100% -- IS
TO BE TWENTY NINE IN I WISH YOU
GUYS LUCK AND WE NEED YOUR
SUPPORT A 100% A MAN THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT CITY [inaudible]
SO -- SO I
JUST.
I JUST BE CLEAR ON THE RULES
HERE -- FOR
TWO WE CANNOT ALLOW CLAPPING OR
OTHER FORMS A DEMONSTRATION IN
THE AUDIENCE.
IF YOU WISH TO SELL YOUR
PLEASURE WITH SOMETHING YOU CAN
DO THIS.
ALL RIGHT THEY ARE A GOOD VERY
GOOD ITEMS FAXING GOODS ALL
RIGHT GOOD SO THAT'S FINE --
NO SIGNS NO CLAPPING NO SORRY
SAID WE JUST THAT THAT'S THE
REAL SELF BUT I APPRECIATE AND
I'M I THINK EVERYONE I KNOW A
LOT PEOPLE TRAVEL VERY FAR TO
COME TESTIFY TODAY IN THE
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT --
SO -- IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
OKAY SEEING NO OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL I QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS --
THEIR STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
SENATOR ALSO WELCOME TO THE AIS
IS THIS YOUR FIRST BILL YES SIR
SENDING.
YOU PRESENTED IT WELL
CONGRATULATIONS AND THANK YOU
SHOOTER PRESENTATION AND I
APPRECIATE --
SO MANY PEOPLE THAT HAVE COME
OUT.
FORGIVE ME BECAUSE I'M KIND OF
LOSING MY VOICE WHICH BATMAN
SIDE I'LL PROBABLY LIKE THAT BUT
YOU'RE SEEING DEMOCRACY IN
ACTION HERE TODAY.
SO -- IN AND
IT'S A IT'S A WONDERFUL
EXPERIMENT --
I'VE BEEN IN THE LEGISLATURE NOW
FOR FOUR YEARS AND STARTING MY
SECOND TERM AND ONE OF MY MY
ISSUES.
BIG ISSUES IN THE STATE HAS BEEN
WITH THE MEDICAL PROGRAM.
THAT --
DURING THE 200-082-0009
RECESSION --
WE GAVE SIGNIFICANT CUTS TO THE
PROGRAM 10%.
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN FULLY
REINSTATED WE WE'VE HAD SOME
PROPOSITION MONEY THIS BEEN BACK
FILLING --
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT.
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH PHYSICIANS
THE WILL PARTICIPATE IN THE
MEDICARE PROGRAM PUTTING MANAGED
CARE ASIDE.
BECAUSE WE JUST DON'T PAY.
AN APPROPRIATE FEE FOR THEM TO
PARTICIPATE [inaudible]
AND SO.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR
JUST RE RELEASED A REPORT --
IT WAS JUST THIS LAST WEEK
MILLIONS OF CHILDREN IN THE
MEDICAL PROGRAM WERE NOT
RECEIVING PREVENTATIVE HEALTH
SERVICES AND I KNOW THAT THE THE
CHAIRMAN UNDERSTANDS AS BEING --
IN THE STEAM THE PEDIATRICIAN.
AN AVERAGE AN ANNUAL AVERAGE OF
TWO POINT FOUR MILLION CHILDREN
ARE ENROLLED IN THE MEDICARE ALL
OVER THE PAST FIVE YEARS AND NOT
RECEIVED ALL OF THE PRESENTED
PREVENTATIVE HEALTH SERVICES
THAT THE STATE IS COMMITTED TO
PROVIDE THEM.
THE CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL
AND PREVENTION PROVIDE CHILDREN
WITH AN ANNUAL PREVENTIVE HEALTH
SERVICES SAVES THOUSANDS OF
LIVES A REDUCES FUTURE HEALTH
COSTS BY THE THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS PER CHILD.
SO ONE OF MY CONCERNS SENATOR IS
THAT WE HAVE A SYSTEM OF HEALTH
CARE DELIVERY.
THAT HAS BEEN BROKEN.
BUT HAS NOT BEEN DELIVERING THE
SERVICES THAT HAVE BEEN PROMISED.
TO THE BENEFICIARIES AS THEY
EXIST TODAY.
BY INCLUDING THIS POPULATION --
WE ARE GOING TO BE ADDING A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF PEOPLE TO
THE MEDICAL ROLES --
AT SIGNIFICANT EXPENSE I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN NO --
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT THIS IS
GONNA COSTS IN THE IN YOUR BILL
BUT I BELIEVE IT'S IN EXCESS OF
TWO BILLION DOLLARS TO PROVIDE
ALL UNDOCUMENTED IS WITH --
MEDI CAL OF SERVICES AND YOU CAN
CORRECT ME CERTAINLY IF I'M
WRONG.
BY ADDING AT THIS NUMBER OF
PEOPLE TO THE EXISTING.
ROLES THAT ARE GOING TO BE SEEN
BY.
THE FEW POSITIONS THAT WE HAVE
IS GOING TO EVEN FOR THE DELUDE.
THE AVAILABILITY OF PHYSICIANS
TO SEE PEOPLE THAT ARE IN THE
SYSTEM TODAY.
SO THE FIRST QUESTION IS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WE NEED TO DO
TO GET THE MEDICAL SYSTEM IN
SHAPE SO THAT WE CAN REALLY SAY
THAT IT IS HEALTHY TO ACCEPT
MORE PATIENCE NUMBER ONE NUMBER --
TWO DO YOU AVE ANY IDEA IF
YOU'RE GOING TO CAP THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE THAT ARE GOING TO BE
ENROLLED IN THIS PROGRAM OR
YOU'RE GOING TO CAP.
THE AMOUNT OF EXPENDITURE IN
THIS PROGRAM BECAUSE I'M GONNA
SUGGESTED OPINED THAT IF WE PASS
THIS IN THE GOVERNOR SIGNS AND
AS HE'S INDICATED THAT HE
PROBABLY WILL.
THAT I WOULD IMAGINE THAT WE ARE
GOING TO SEE MORE IMMIGRANTS
COMING INTO CALIFORNIA TO SEEK
THE SERVICES THAT --
SO WE DON'T HEAR SOME OF THE
TERRIBLE STORIES THAT WE WE SEE
SO.
IF YOU CANCEL QUESTIONS HERE.
WELL LET ME START WITH THE LAST --
ONE I'VE SPENT MOST OF MY ADULT
LIFE.
WITH --
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES AND IMMIGRANT
WORKERS.
AND I CAN ASSURE YOU.
THAT THE REASON THEY COME TO
THIS COUNTRY IS NOT FOR THE
HEALTH [inaudible]
HEALTH CARE.
ON THAT IS NOT WHAT DRIVES THEM.
WHAT DRIVES THEM IS WHAT PUSHES
THEM OUT OF THEIR RESPECTIVE
COUNTRIES? EIGHT LIVE IN
ABSOLUTE.
LIFE AND DEATH POVERTY THAT IS
WHY THEY RISK THEIR LIVES THAT
IS WHY HUNDRED DIE EACH YEAR.
CROSSING THE BORDER.
SO AT THAT KIND OF CLARITY OR
THEY FACE ENORMOUS VIOLENCE.
IN WHICH THEY CAN.
EVERY DAY MEMBERS OF THE
FAMILIES FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS
ARE GETTING KILLED BECAUSE OF
THE VIOLENCE SO.
I ASSURE YOU AFTER MANY DECK
COMMUNITY.
HEALTH INSURANCE OR HAVING A
DRIVER'S LICENSE OR ANYTHING
LIKE THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
WHAT DRIVES THEM THEY WOULD
PREFER TO STAY IN THEIR HOME
COUNTRIES.
ARM WITH REGARDS --
TO YOU KNOW I AM NOT YET AN
EXPERT ON MEDI CAL SO I I
COULDN'T PRETEND TO ANSWER SOME
OF YOUR QUESTIONS AND THERE MAY
BE OTHERS.
HERE BUT I WOULD SAY.
OF WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR IS AN
EFFICIENT SYSTEM.
AN EFFICIENT SYSTEM THAT GIVES
HEALTH CARE. TO ALL.
IN SUCH A WAY THAT WE DON'T HAVE
TO RESORT. TO ONLY EMERGENCY
SERVICES --
AND I THINK WE SHOULD GET MORE
OF THOSE NUMBERS.
BABY TO TERM FOR ME TO REALLY
BACKED THAT UP BUT I KNOW HAVING
BEEN INVOLVED WITH HEALTH CARE --
PLANS. FOR OVER DECADES.
THAT AND WE ALWAYS HAD TO
NEGOTIATE WITH THE PROVIDERS AND
TO SAY KEEP PEOPLE AWAY FROM THE
EMERGENCY ROOM BECAUSE THE COST
IS SO HIGH.
AND RIGHT NOW WHAT WE'RE DOING
IS WE'RE PUSHING THEM TO THE
EMERGENCY ROOMS WE'RE STILL
PAYING CALIFORNIANS ARE PAIN FOR
THOSE EMERGENCY ROOM SERVICES
WE'RE PAYING FOR LAST MINUTE.
UP VISITS --
SO IT'S NOT LIKE THERE THERE AND
WE'RE NOT PUTTING OUT ANY MONEY
RIGHT NOW WE'RE PAYING.
QUESTION FOR US IS DO WE HAVE A
SMARTER PLAN. TO COVER THEM AT
THE GIVEN THE ATTENTION.
WE IF WE DO NOT GIVE IT IT'S NOT
JUST THE INDIVIDUAL FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO SUFFER.
BUT IMAGINE THE PREVENT THE
PREVENTION OF DIABETES THE
PREVENTION OF RESPIRATORY.
AILMENTS THERE'S SO MANY THINGS
THAT COST US.
BILLIONS I CAN GUARANTEE YOU
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
SO WHEN ARE WE GOING TO GET
SMARTER.
ABOUT THINKING THAT SOMEHOW
WE'RE SAVING MONEY WHEN IN FACT
WE'RE SPENDING MORE.
SO -- I'M
SORRY I DON'T HAVE THE EXACT
NUMBERS FOR YOU AND WE'LL WORK
ON IT MAYBE THERE'S SOMEONE HERE
WHO.
CAN PROVIDE THAT --
BUT THAT'S THE WAY I'VE SEEN.
THAT'S BEEN MY EXPERIENCE MY
WHOLE LIFE I APPRECIATE YOUR
ANSWERS AND AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMPASSION AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR PASSION. FOR WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH HERE TODAY --
I'M UNFORTUNATELY NOT GOING TO
GO TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY AND
NOT LET ME EXPLAIN WHY.
IT'S NOT THAT I DON'T BELIEVE WE
ARE NOT A COMPASSIONATE STATE I
THINK WE ARE COMPASSIONATE STATE
WHEN I USE MY PERSONAL MONEY.
HI I DONATE TO CAUSES THAT HELP
UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE IN MY
DISTRICT --
BUT WE'RE TALKING NOW ABOUT
TAXPAYER MONEY.
AND USUALLY WHEN YOU LOOK AT
BILLS YOU HAVE TO MAKE A NEXUS
TO THE BUDGET OF THE STATE.
AND SO THIS IS GOING TO BE --
A VERY EXPENSIVE --
LAW.
IN EXCESS OF TWO BILLION DOLLARS
MAYBE MORE AS YOU PROBABLY SAID.
SO IT BASICALLY COMES TO A
MATTER OF PRIORITIZATION IN THE
STATE BUDGET.
AND WE ARE A STATE THAT HAS SOME
SIGNIFICANT ISSUES WE HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT HOMELESS ISSUE.
WE HAVE ROUGHLY A HUNDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND HOMELESS PEOPLE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
PROBABLY MORE THAN ANY OTHER
STATE PER CAPITA --
WE HAVE --
VETERANS THAT ARE IN DIRE NEED
OF OF HELP --
WE HAVE SENIOR CITIZENS THAT ARE
STRUGGLING TO STAY IN THEIR
HOMES -- SO.
AS WE LOOK AT BILLS LIKE THIS WE
GOT TO TAKE IT IN THE CONTEXT OF
PRIORITIZING THE THE NEEDS OF OF
THE STATE.
AND IF IF MONEY WAS LIMóN LESS
I WOULD BE JOINING YOU 1100% THE
MONEY IS NOT LIMITLESS IT IS
FINITE.
AND BASED ON THE NUMBERS ARE
COMING INTO THE STATE COFFERS
THESE DAYS --
WE'RE SEEING --
MAYBE A DOWNWARD TREND IN OUR
PROJECTIONS.
SO IN THAT WILL LIMIT WHAT ARE
SPENDING CAN BE.
BUT I THINK THAT THESE OTHER
NEEDS AND AND OUR CHILDREN --
THAT WE'VE BEEN APART PROVIDE
EARLY HEAD CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
ALL THESE PROGRAMS HAVE PRICE
TAGS.
AND I THINK IN MY MIND THOSE
ALREADY RIGHT NOW FOR THOSE
CITIZENS THAT ARE HERE.
THAT ARE DOCUMENTED AND THEN WE
HAVE THE KIND OF MONEY THAT WE
CAN AFFORD TO TAKE CARE OF OTHER
POPULATIONS IN AND PHILANTHROPIC
AND CHARITABLE WAYS I WON HER
PERCENT BEHIND IT.
BUT AT THIS POINT TIME I CREDIT
ADDRESS THE PROBLEMS THAT WE
HAVE IN THE STATE THEY WERE
HAVING TROUBLE FINDING THESE
THESE DAYS AND AT BUT IT
PROCEDURE YOUR PASSION AND YOU
BRING IN THE BEFORE.
THANK YOU ASSN RUBIO.
THANK YOU.
WELL FIRST OF ALL LET ME THANK
GOD.
OUR COLLEAGUE US SENATOR DROPS
OF FOR BRINGING THIS ISSUE UP
AND DIE I TO ONE OF ALLOCATE
SOME OF THE THE COMMENTS THAT MR
STONE MADE IN TERMS OF A SYSTEM
THAT WHERE WE HAVE CHILDREN THAT
NEED SERVICES ARE NOT GETTING
SERVICES WITH.
MY OPINION THAT'S UNACCEPTABLE
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE GETS THE CARE THAT THEY
DESERVE --
BUT I ALSO WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE THAT CAME TO SPEAK
TODAY SOMETIMES IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT.
FOR ALL OF OUR COLLEAGUES AND
MYSELF APPEAR TO SEE THE FACES
BEHIND THE STORIES I APPRECIATE
THAT WHAT YOU ARE SHARING I
HEARD A COUPLE OF SPEAKERS --
DISCUSS SOME OF THEIR LOVED ONES
THAT ARE NO LONGER WITH US AND
SO THANK YOU FOR THAT TIME --
AND I KNOW THAT OUR COLLEAGUE OF
MR ALSO WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH US AND PROVIDE US THE
INFORMATION WE NEED --
AND IF I MAY I WANT TO SEE IF
YOU YEAH.
OKAY YEAH THAT'LL IS A GLASS OF
CIRCLES BUT IS THAT A KEY IS
MORE IMPORTANT THEY THAT LESS
GOT US A BILL OF PERSONAL
NOTHING PARKED OUT US UP OR NOT
BEEN AS THEY WILL.
AYE SCANDAL HAVING IT ALL.
FREE DOCUMENT THAT I ONLY ONE
CAN BE SPOTTED IS STILL COMPETE
IN THE LINES THEY WOULD BE DONE.
BY SEALING EVE STATUS SEKI
AUSTIN ON THE FINANCE YEAH
GARCIA.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
FOR REMEMBER [inaudible]
OKAY.
BUT ACTUALLY CENTER MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
MISTER CHAIR US SINCE WE ARE IN
THE POLICY COMMITTEE I'M GOING
TO FOCUS MY QUESTIONS ON THE
POLICY OF THE BILL NOT THE PRICE
TAG.
I'M SURE THEY'LL BE PLENTY OF
TIME IN APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
TO TALK ABOUT COST --
MR ALSO -- I
DO HAVE A CONCERN WITH REGARD TO
PUBLIC CHARGE --
A DEEP CONCERN THAT IF THE STATE
WERE TO STEP UP AND AND MAKE.
MEDI CAL --
AVAILABLE TO ALL THOSE WHO WOULD
OTHERWISE BE ELIGIBLE BUT FOR
THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS.
GIVEN --
WHAT'S GOING ON AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL NOW ARTS WORK COUNTIES
ACROSS THE STATE ARE SEEN --
MIXED STATUS FAMILIES WHO WHO
ARE NOT.
ARE SIGNING UP FOR PROGRAMS THAT
THEY ARE ELIGIBLE FOR OUT OF
FEAR.
OF THE ISSUE OF PUBLIC CHARGE
AND THAT IT WILL BE LEVERAGED
AGAINST THEM BY THIS FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT --
DO YOU SHARE MY SAME CONCERN --
WITH REGARD TO PUBLIC CHARGIN
AND IF NOT WHY WILL WHAT COULD
WE DO IF THIS WERE TO BECOME LAW.
TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE DO
INDEED STEP UP AND SIGN UP
BECAUSE THE CHALLENGE WILL BE.
IF WE INDEED FUND MEDI CAL FOR
ALL VERY LIKELY THERE WILL BE AN
EXPECTATION THAT WEWILL REAP
SAVINGS FROM THE SAFETY NET
AREAS WHERE.
THIS POPULATION CURRENTLY
RECEIVE SERVICES.
SO I WOULDN'T WANT US TO PULL
DOLLARS BACK FROM THOSE AREAS
WELL WE DON'T GET THE UP TAKE A
MEDI CAL ENROLLMENT OUT OF FEAR.
YOU FOLLOW ME.
WHAT WHAT SAY YOU [inaudible]
WELL --
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE FINAL
OBVIOUSLY WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
FINAL DECISION WILL BE ON PUBLIC
CHARGE.
WE DON'T KNOW HOW BROAD OR HOW
DEEP THE DEFINITION OF PUBLIC
CHARGE COULD BE ARE IN FACT IT
COULD BE.
FOR GETTING A FREE MEAL.
ALL IN SCHOOL.
IF IF THERE ARE THOSE WHO ARE
EVIL ENOUGH TO PUT THAT FORWARD.
I DON'T THINK THEN THAT SHOULD
PUSHES BACK FROM.
CONTINUING TO PROVIDE THE NEEDS
OF THIS COMMUNITY I THINK THIS
COULD BE A NEEDS TO CONTINUE TO
PARTICIPATE AT EVERY LEVEL.
I'D I WOULD BE MORE CONCERNED
ABOUT THIS COMMUNITY --
BY THE GOING FURTHER UNDERGROUND.
ON A ON A LOT OF OTHER LEVELS
AND IT IS A BIG CONCERN.
I DON'T THINK THAT SHOULD HOLD
US BACK THAT WERE THEIR
UNDERGROUND MAYBE IF WE PUT
RESOURCES AND THERE WE COULD GET
MORE INCOME TO THE STATE LIKE
WAY TO THE LEFT.
ALL WAGE THEFT --
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ALL BY ITSELF COULD PAY
FOR THIS AND MORE HEALTH CARE.
SO MAYBE IF WE INVESTED OUR
RESOURCES THE RIGHT WAY NOT ONLY
WOULD WE ADDRESS WAGE THEFT AND
BRING IN MORE MONEY BUT WE WOULD
BEGIN TO DEMONSTRATE TO THE
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY.
THAT THIS STATE.
REALLY SEES EVERYONE AS EQUALS
WE'RE GONNA APPLY OUR
PROTECTIONS ACROSS THE BOARD IN
THE LEGAL WAY --
I'M SURE THERE IS A MORE
TECHNICAL WAY TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION BUT I HAVE NEVER.
SEEN [inaudible]
US WITHDRAW.
WHEN THERE'S FURTHER ATTACKS ON
THE RIGHTS AND ON THE COMMUNITY
AND THE LIVELIHOOD OF THE
COMMUNITY WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THAT ON MANY WAY ON
MANY FRONTS ON THE CENSUS FRONT?
THERE ARE MANY WAYS IN WHICH OUR
COMMUNITY WILL WANT TO BE
FURTHER PUSHED OUT AND WAY.
AND WE'RE REALLY GOING TO HAVE
TO STEP UP AND THIS IS ONE WAY
OF CONTINUING TO STEP UP FOR
THIS PART OF OUR COMMUNITY.
I T<c.cyan> I THANK YOU FOR THAT</c>
RESPONSE I I JUST THINK THAT --
IT IS THE VERY REAL --
BARRIER ON AND WE'RE SEEING IT
IN EXISTING PROGRAMS AND AND WE
SHOULD BE MINDFUL OF YOU KNOW IF
THIS WERE TO BECOME LAW WE
SHOULD MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS A
CONCERTED EFFORT IN TERMS OF OUT
REGION EDUCATE THAT WE SHOULDN'T
BE A REALISTIC IN TERMS OF OUR
UP.
TAKE NUMBERS --
WE SHOULD YOU KNOW BASE OUR
EXPERIENCE OUR REALITY VERSES.
AREWANT FOR EVERYONE TO HAVE
HEALTHCARE AND SO I JUST WANT TO
BE MINDFUL THAT THIS IS IS.
THAT IF CALIFORNIA WHERE TO DO
IT IT'S NOT HAPPEN IN A VACUUM
IT IS A PIECE OF A BROADER --
CONVERSATION AROUND THE
EXPERIENCE OF A OF AN IMMIGRANT
IMMIGRANT FAMILY IN THIS COUNTRY
AND IN THE STATE I JUST THINK
WANT US TO BE MINDFUL ON A GO
FORWARD BASIS --
ABOUT HOW WE WOULD DO OUT REACH
WHO THE KEY MESSAGES WOULD BE
ABOUT -- HAD
A ROLE IN THIS PROGRAM ECSTATIC
CETERA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU --
LEYVA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
APOLOGIZE FOR BEING LATE I WAS
PRESENTING A BILL AN
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY HAD REALLY
WANTED TO HEAR FROM EVERYONE.
BUT I JUST WANT TO THINK OF
SENATOR ALSO FOR REALLY HITTING
THE GROUND RUNNING AFTER SHE WAS
ELECTEDIN BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD --
HEALTH CARE WHEN I LOOK AROUND
THE ROOM AND I LOOK AT EVERY
SINGLE PERSON IN THIS ROOM.
WE ARE ALL THE SAME WE ARE ALL
PART OF THE HUMAN RACE WE ALL
HAVE A BODY AND OUR HEALTH AS
INDICATED BY MS CENTER STONE.
OUR HEALTH IS FINITE AND IT IS
NOT INFINITE AND IF WE DON'T
TAKE CARE OF OURSELVES OR WERE
NOT ALLOWED TO TAKE CARE OF
OURSELVES BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE.
THAT OUR LIFESPAN IS SHORTENED
AND EVERY SINGLE PERSON IN THIS
ROOM HAS SOMETHING TO OFFER
EVERY SINGLE PERSON IN THIS ROOM
HAS SOMETHING TO CONTRIBUTE TO
SUCCESS SOCIETY.
I LOOK FORWARD TO A TIME WHEN
HEALTH CARE IS NOT A PRIVILEGE
AND IT IS A RIGHT THAT EVERY
SINGLE PERSON IN THIS COUNTRY IN
THIS STATE HAS THE RIGHT TO
RECEIVE HEALTH CARE.
WHEN THEY NEED IT MOST OF YOU
KNOW BEFORE I CAME HERE?
AND I STILL REMEMBER THE SIXTY
TWO THOUSAND WORKERS WHO WENT ON
STRIKE AT ALBERTSONS RALPHS VONS
THAT WAS IN 200-032-0004.
SO THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT I WOULD WANT TO BE ON
THE FRONT LINES WITH YOU
FIGHTING.
FOR UNTIL WE MAKE IT HAPPEN SO I
THINK YOU AND I WOULD LIKE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR NGUYEN EVER
APPROPRIATE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SO -- I I
JUST WANNA SAY FIRST OF ALL --
THANK YOU SENATOR AS A FOR RAIN
THIS BILL FORD AND THAT'S GREAT
THIS IS THE FIRST BILL OR
HEARING AND THE SESSION FOR OUR
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH AND SO --
SO IT'S A PLEASURE FOR ME IS THE
CHAIR OF THE HAT TO HEAR THIS
BILL FIRST AND DOES WELL AS I
KNOW THIS IS YOUR FIRST BILL
PRESENTING HERE.
TODAY.
I AGREE WITH YOU THAT --
THAT OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM ARE --
STATE IT IS MORE EFFICIENT IF WE
ACTUALLY GET EVERYONE IN.
WITH MORE EFFICIENT --
I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND AND I
HAVE MY GOOD FRIEND THE CENTER
STONE NINE WE WITH ALONG WITH
CENTER TADO WE SIT UNDER THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE --
NO WE WE WANT TO MAKE MEDI CAL
BETTER --
BUT I WOULD ALSO SAY THAT --
IT FOR ALL THE FLAWS THAT WE
HAVE IN OUR MEDICAL PROGRAM IN
DECEMBER IT'S A GOOD PROGRAM IN
MANY WAYS THERE'S CHALLENGES AND
OTHERS.
IT'S CERTAINLY BETTER TO BE A
MEDIC HOW THE AB STRAIGHT SO SO
SO WE NEED TO GIVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY --
I ALSO --
RECOGNIZE AND APPRECIATE --
SIR MITCHELL'S WAS THEM ABOUT
THE REALITY ON THE GROUND --
BUT CERTAINLY WITHOUT YOUR BILL
WE NEED TO GIVE THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY IF THEY WISH TO SIGN
UP RIGHT I MEAN THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO I MEAN WE
HAVE WORK TO DO ON THE GROUND.
WE STILL KNOW HOW NEED TO
SUPPORT CLINICS IS OVER BECAUSE
IT WILL BE PEOPLE WHO WILL BE
FEARFUL OF SIGNING UP
[inaudible]
AND UNFORTUNATELY.
DODD --
BECAUSE OF RULES REGULATIONS
COMING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT --
DEATH YOU MAY HAVE SOME REALITY
AND WE STILL HAVE TO PROVIDE
THEM ALTERNATE OPTIONS THEY MAY
NOT BE WILLING.
TO BUT WITHOUT YOUR BILL WE CAN
EVEN OFFER THEM THE OPPORTUNITY
EITHER THEY OVERCAME THIS YEAR.
SO -- WE
CERTAINLY HAVE YOU KNOW THIS IS
A POLICY COMMITTEE SO WE SELL TO
WORK ON THE MONEY SIDE.
AT ONE HITS APPROPRIATIONS --
BUT CERTAINLY IN MY VIEW --
OUR POLICY SHOULD BE TOWARD
TRYING TO ACHIEVE UNIVERSAL
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE HEALTHCARE
IS A RIGHT AND THAT --
AND THIS IS CERTAINLY A MAJOR
STEP FORWARD IN THAT DIRECTION
AND SO WITH THAT CERTAINLY --
I URGE THE I SELL I HEARD IN
MOTION --
WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE AND DRAWS SO.
AGAIN I THE SENATE THOSE MAKES
AND MODELS IN A MINUS CAMBIADO
BOTTLE OF THIS STUFF A LITTLE
THANK YOU ALL FOR TRAVELING FOR
SO FAR AND THANK YOU TO MY
SISTERS AND BROTHERS.
ON THIS COMMITTEE FOR ALL THE
WORK THAT YOU HAVE DONE ALL ARE
ON THE ISSUE OF HEALTH CARE AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE OKAY THANK YOU NOW BEFORE
WE ACTUALLY VOTE ON THIS BILL --
WE ACTUALLY HAVE TO FORMALLY
ABOUT THEIR COMMITTEE RULES --
SO SO THAT'S WHERE WE GET AWAY
WITH DOING STUFF BEFORE BUT NOW
INTO THAT ON THE RULES HE BETTER
NOT.
SAID THERE'S A MOTION ON THE
RULES BUT SINCE CENTER MITCHELL
SO FIRST ON THE ROOF COMMITTEE
RULES SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. TEN HI AND I STONE DORADO.
DRAWS -- I
GROWTH.
HER TADO HER TOTAL AYE LEYVA.
AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL IS AYE.
MONNING RUBIO HI RUBIO BY.
OKAY AND I SO THE RULES ARE
ADOPTED DEAF BUT THE SIX SIX AYE
VOTES ALL RIGHT.
THAT'S FINE.
OKAY WHICH EXCITED TO THE RULES
WERE FORMALLY ADOPTED OKAY NOW
THAT THE RULES ARE ADOPTED --
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON SB
TWENTY NINE WHICH WAS --
SECONDED BY CENTER MITCHELL.
PAN HI AND I STONE.
DORADO.
DORADO I GROWTH FURTADO.
TACOS I LEYVA LEYVA AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING RUBIO HI
RUBIO HI.
SO THE BILL CURRENTLY HAS SIX
VOTES FOR JUST ENOUGH TO GET IT
PASSED BUT WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN UNTIL THE OTHER MEMBERS ARE
ABLE TO ADD ON THE FORTY
ACTUALLY CLOSE THE ROLE SELF.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND RAZA.
ALL RIGHT --
NEXT TIME ON THE AGENDA ACTUALLY
US ARE LEYVA BECAUSE THAT YOU'RE
ALWAYS GOES LAST --
SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER SIX SB.
THREE OH ONE AND THEN --
FALL THAT WITH ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
AS CHAIR FOR UNLESS YOU TO TAKE
A DIFFERENT ORDER.
OKAY ALL RIGHT. ONE TWENTY OF US.
FORTY ONE ON CONSENT BUT JUST.
SHE BUT I WAS COME LAST.
THAT IS WHEN YOU KNOW.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
OKAY SORRY --
IF -- IF
ACTUALLY I CAN ASK.
I KNOW THE EVENTS LEADING IF WE
CAN TRY TO DO IT QUIETLY SO
CENTER LEYVA CAN PRESENTER BILL
SO WE HAVE THAT NUMBER ITEM
NUMBER SIX SB THREE OH ONE
WELCOME --
ACTUALLY TO WIN THIS IS A COMING
UP HERE.
OKAY SO IF I JUST WANNA SAY THAT
I'M HEARTBROKEN THAT EVERYONE IS
LEAVING AND DOESN'T WANT TO HEAR
MY FABULOUS BILLS BUT YOU KOW.
SUCH IS LIFE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I WANT TO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR YOUR HARD
WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL IT
IS MUCH APPRECIATED.
I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS ON THE LAST PAGE OF
THE ANALYSIS. FOR MANY YEARS
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE A CONCERTED
EFFORT TO EXPAND AND PROTECT
FAMILY PLANNING SERVICES.
RECENT CHANGES IN FEDERAL
POLICIES JEOPARDIZE ACCESS TO
QUALITY FAMILY PLANNING SERVICES.
FAMILY PACK IS A MEDICAID
PROGRAM ADMINISTERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES.
DH CS.
THE PROGRAM PROVIDES LOW INCOME
WOMEN AND MEN WITH ACCESS TO
FAMILY PLANNING SERVICES FAMILY
BACK SERVICE SERVICES INCLUDE
ALL FDA APPROVED CONTRACEPTIVE
MESSAGE METHODS.
EMERGENCY CONTRACEPTIVES TESTING
AND TREATMENT OF SEXUALLY
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED INFECTIONS
AND URINARY TRACT INFECTIONS
ALONG WITH SCREENINGS FOR BREAST
AND CERVICAL CANCER.
FAMILY PICTURES ONE POINT ONE
MILLION LOW INCOME AND UNINSURED
INDIVIDUALS IN CALIFORNIA.
THROUGH TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE PROVIDERS
CURRENTLY FAMILY PACK IS FUNDED
BY A NINETY TEN FEDERAL MATCH
MEANING THAT FOR EVERY ONE
DOLLAR INVESTED IN FAMILY
PLANNING CARE.
THE STATE RECEIVES NINETY CENTS
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS FEDERAL
PROPOSALS IN TWO STATES FORM
PROPOSAL OR OTHER SIMILAR NATURE
OR TO BE IMPLEMENTED THE CURRENT
MATCH FOR FAMILY PLANNING
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA COULD BE
THREATENED.
WITHOUT A PLAN IN PLACE ACCESS
TO FAMILY PLANNING SERVICES FOR
LOW INCOME AND ENSURE
CALIFORNIANS COULD BE DISRUPTED
AND SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED SB
THREE ONE PROVIDES A FRAMEWORK
FOR THAT PLANNING.
IN THE EVENT OF REDUCTIONS IN
FEDERAL FUNDING SB THREE OH ONE
WOULD REQUIRE DH CS. TO SUBMIT A
PLAN TO THE LEGISLATURE WITHIN
SIXTY DAYS OF ANY FEDERAL ACTION
THAT WOULD ALTER CURRENT
FINANCING ENSURING THE
SUSTAINABILITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
FAMILY PACK PROGRAM.
HERE WITH ME IN SUPPORT IS
SYLVIA CASTILLO FROM ESSENTIAL
ACCESS HEALTH. EIGHT THANK YOU
WELCOME.
THANK YOU CENTER LEYVA AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
MY NAME'S OF THE CASPIAN I'M
HERE REPRESENTING ESSENTIAL
ACCESS HEALTH OF WHEAT A
CHAMPION PROMOTE QUALITY SECTION
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE FOR ALL.
AND WE ACHIEVE OUR MISSION DOING
UMBRELLA PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
INCLUDING ADVANCE CLINICAL
RESEARCH --
PROVIDER TRAINING CLINICAL
CLINIC SUPPORT INITIATIVES AND
ADVOCACY AND CONSUMER AWARENESS --
THE STATE LEGISLATURE
ESTABLISHED THE FAMILY PROGRAM
IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX AS A
MEDICAID WAIVER DEMONSTRATION
PROJECT WITH THE GOAL OF PROVING
THE COST EFFECTIVENESS OF MAKING
FAMILY PLANNING CARE WIDELY
ACCESSIBLE.
AND THE PROGRAM HAS CONTINUOUSLY
PROVEN ITS SUCCESS.
PROGRAM EVALUATIONS CONDUCTED BY
THE UC SAN FRANCISCO UC SAN
FRANCISCO HAS SHOWN MULTIPLE
TIMES THAT EVERY DOLLAR SPENT ON
THE PROGRAM.
THE PUBLIC SECTOR SAVE MORE THAN
NINE DOLLARS AND PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SOCIAL WELFARE EXPENSES.
OVER THE PAST THREE DECADES
FAMILY PACKED AND THE TITLE TEN
FEDERAL FAMILY PLANNING PROGRAM
HAVE PARTNERED TO REDUCE
UNINTENDED PREGNANCY RATES IN
OUR STATE O HISTORIC LOWS.
IN THE IN THE LAST THIRTY IN IN
A THIRTY FOR YOUR REDUCE ITS
TEEN PREGNANCY RATE BY 70% AND
THIS IS LARGELY THANKS TO THE
FAMILY PACK PROGRAM.
TRUMP PENT ADMINISTRATION HAS
ALREADY ATTACKED HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE AND ACCESS TO SEXUAL A
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES.
INCLUDING ALSO ATTEMPTING TO
SHIFT MEDICAID FUNDING INTO
BLOCK FUNDING WHICH WOULD
THREATEN THE NINETY TEN THE
NINETY TEN A FUNDING MATCH BY
THE FAT FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
CALIFORNIA MUST TAKE STEPS TO
PLAN FOR ALL SCENARIOS INCLUDING
A POTENTIAL FUNDING LOSS FOR THE
FAMILY PACK PROGRAM.
A TO PROTECT ACCESS TO VITAL
HEALTH CARE SERVICES SO
CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY ENACTED
SEVERAL MEASURES TO HOLD THE
LINE AND PROTECT ACCESS TO
SEXUAL HEALTH CARE SERVICES IN
THE FACE OF HOSTILE.
ACTIONS ON THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
AND SO SB THRILL ONE WOULD CALL
ON THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO CREATE A
SUSTAINABILITY PLAN FOR FAMILY
PACK SHOULD FEDERAL FUNDING
CHANGES OCCUR.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YEAR HI
VOTE.
OKAY THANK YOU.
ARE THERE OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
PLEASE COME TO THE FACT
MICROPHONE NAME WAS A BOOK.
IF I COULD NOT.
WE WERE VERY EXCITED RIGHT
[inaudible]
ALL OF NINE OKAY ACTUALLY S. IS
A WAY WE CAN TURN THE MICROPHONE
ON CALIFORNIANS.
SORRY IT'S ALSO FOR THE RECORD
ON THE THANKS SO.
OKAY OKAY BANKS HERE HI THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS MAY
INSUBRES ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTH PLUS ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
OKAY.
RIGHT SPENCER WITH AMERICAN
COLLEGE OBGYN STASHED NINE IN
SUPPORT.
I AND GRAHAM A SILLY OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
YOU'VE GOT YOUR GOALS ON
BUILDINGS LEGAL CENTER INLAND
EMPIRE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MORNING CARAMEL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RESIDENTS HALLS WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN SUPPORT. EIGHTY NINE
AND WE HEAR FROM MY AGE AND
HEALTH SERVICES IN OAKLAND WE
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
FACING OTHER.
OKAY THE BILLS INTO ART --
SEEN OTHER PEOPLE MICROPHONE IS
A ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY SAYING NONE QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY SEEING NONE.
THANK YOU CENTER LIVE A FAMILY
PRACTICE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT BE
SURE -- WE
GET ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE --
AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH FOR BOTH
WOMEN AND AT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
OKAY -- SO --
THE BILL IS SPEND SECONDED BY
SENATOR MITCHELL --
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS AT SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AM I AND IS AYE STONE.
TORONTO ON DRUGS OR I GROWTH.
HER TADA.
THE TITLE I LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE
MITCHELL AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING.
MONNING AYE RUBIO.
AYE RUBIO AYE.
OKAY SO THE BILL CURRENTLY A
SEVEN FOOT BOATS WHICH IS ENOUGH
TO GET IT OUT OF WHEN THE HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
WHEN WE MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN S. T. R.?
FOR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON AGAIN MEMBERS.
TITLE TEN IS A FEDERALLY FUNDED
PROGRAM DEDICATED TO FAMILY
PLANNING SERVICES THESE
IMPORTANT SERVICES INCLUDE
CONTRACEPTIVE CARE PREGNANCY
TESTING DIAGNOSING AND TREATING
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED INFECTIONS.
INFERTILITY SERVICES AND
PREGNANCY OPTION COUNSELING'S I
KNOW THIS SOUNDS VERY SIMILAR TO
WHAT I JUST TALKED TO YOU ABOUT
THIS ONE IS FEDERAL THE OTHER
ONE WAS STATE --
RESPECT WESTERN AYE VOTE.
OKAY I ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
JOSEPHINE FIGUEROA ON BEHALF OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER GOT A LOT
OF SUPPORT.
OKAY THE DESERT TESTIMONY
SUPPORT OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY SORRY [inaudible]
OF THANK YOU ARE STILL VACANCY%
AGAIN WITH ESSENTIAL ACCESS
HEALTH WE ARE THE PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATOR WHERE THE ONE
WHERE THE FEDERAL GRANT T. HERE
IN CALIFORNIA THE ONLY.
ONE AND WE SUB GRANT OUT THIS
FEDERAL FUNDING TO OVER THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX CLINICS
ACROSS THE STATE THAT SERVE A
FAMILY.
MORE THAN ONE MILLION PATIENTS
PROVIDING THEM FAMILY PLANNING
CARE ACROSS THIRTY EIGHT
COUNTIES IN THE STATE --
SOME OF THE AGENCIES RECEIVE
THEM THESE FINDINGS ARE
FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CENTERS URBAN INDIAN HEALTH
CENTERS UNIVERSITY AFFILIATES
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES
AND OTHER STANDALONE WOMEN'S
HEALTH CENTERS.
A FEW CITY AND COUNTY PUBLIC IN.
THE TULARE COUNTY SAN BERNARDINO
LOS ANGELES SAN LUIS OBISPO
BUTTE NEVADA COUNTY SAN
FRANCISCO AND THE CITY OF
BERKLEY.
THESE TITLE TO REGULATIONS ARE
HARMFUL AND UNLAWFUL AND WE ARE
THANKFUL FOR CENTER LABELS
LEADERSHIP IN INTRODUCING THIS
RESOLUTION.
SUPPORTING THE TITLE TEN PROGRAM
AND CALLING ON HHS TO RESCIND
THE REGULATIONS ANDWE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN THE BACK AND THAT
SOMEONE ELSE IS OUT THERE YOU GO.
SORRY. EIGHT USE THAT YELLOW
STILL TAKE LEGAL CENTER INLAND
EMPIRE IN SUPPORT.
EXCELLENT SEEN OTHER PEOPLE MAKE
PHONE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SAYING NONE QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY IT'S BEEN SECONDED BY A
CENTER MITCHELL --
THE MOTION IS THAT IT BE ADOPTED
IN ORDER TO THIRD READING --
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CAN HI I STONE DORADO.
DRUGS ARE I GROW.
POTATOES.
TOTAL AYE LEYVA.
MONNING I RUBIO [inaudible]
RUBIO I THE BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN TILL
MISTER CHAIR THE MEMBERS --
SO THE NEXT BILL IS ACTUALLY --
ITEM NUMBER FOUR WHICH IS MINE
SO SENATOR TED YOU WHICH TAKE
THE GAVEL.
NO WE HAVEN'T [inaudible]
THERE [inaudible]
I WANT.
HELLO CENTER PAN WELCOME THANK
YOU THANKS VERY MUCH AND THE
BOOK OVER TO VINCE IN ALREADY
HERE OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CHAIR --
ENTERED ALRIGHT SB ONE FIFTY
FOUR WILL MAKE SILVER DIAMOND
FLOWRIDER STF AVAILABLE FIRST
DATA CAL BENEFICIARIES
PARTICULARLY YOUNG CHILDREN
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES AND
ADULTS IN SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES. TO THE K. IS THE
MOST COMMON CHRONIC CONDITION
EXPERIENCED BY CHILDREN.
EVEN AS A PEDIATRICIAN I HAVE TO
MEET THAT --
FAR MORE COMMON THAN ASTHMA OR
HAY FEVER STF IS A TOPICAL
MEDICATION USED TO SLOW DOWN OR
STOP DENTAL DECAY IN BOTH THE
BABY AND PERMANENT TEETH.
SILVER KILLS THE BACTERIA AND
STOPS NEW BACTERIA FROM GROWING.
AND THE FLUORIDE RE MINERALIZED
IS A HARD TO TO STRUCTURE IN
ADDITION TO SURROUNDING TEETH
MAY ALSO RECEIVE ANTI COUNTY
PROTECTION.
SINCE.
THIS TREATMENT AS OFFICIAL FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE LIMITED ACCESS TO
DENTAL TREATMENT AND PRESENT
CHALLENGES READING RECEIVING
TRADITIONAL TREATMENT BECAUSE OF
THEIR AGE BEHAVIORAL ISSUES OR
MEDICAL CONDITIONS.
PRIVATE PRACTICE AND IT'S ARE
INCREASINGLY USING STF TO STOP
DENTAL DECAY IN AT LEAST
THIRTEEN OTHER STATES COVER THIS
TREATMENT IN THE MEDICAID
PROGRAM.
THE BILL REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO MAKE SB
A COVERED BENEFIT. FOR DEBT TO
CAL ENROLLEES AS A TREATMENT
OPTION.
FOR TOOTH DECAY I EXPECT WE ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE NAY WITNESSES
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
DARIA GREW ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING NEARLY TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND MEMBER DENTISTS ACROSS
THE STATE.
PROBABLY SPONSORING SB.
ONE FIFTY FOUR AS DOCTOR PAN
SAID THE BILL ADDS SILVER
DIAMOND FLUORIDE AS A DENTAL
BENEFIT FOR SOME MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES COMPARED TO
TRADITIONAL.
DRILLING THAT REQUIRES SHOTS OF
LOCAL ANESTHETIC AND I'M.
BUT AND DRILLING OF THE TO
STRUCTURE.
THIS TREATMENT IS NON INVASIVE
MORE COMFORTABLE FOR THE PATIENT.
AND LESS EXPENSIVE.
LET'S TALK A LOOK TOPICAL LIQUID
THAT IS SIMPLY BRUSHED ON TO THE
CAVITY THAT CAN PREVENT CURRENT
DECAY AND ALSO PREVENT NEW
DISEASE PROGRESSION IN THE
FUTURE.
IT MAY NOT FULLY ELIMINATE THE
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL DENTAL CARE
TREATMENT BUT DENNIS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE ARE ALREADY
INCORPORATING THIS IN THEIR
PRACTICE.
ARE DENNIS FIND IT CAN BE
PARTICULARLY BENEFICIAL FOR THE
CARE OF CERTAIN POPULATIONS AS
DOCTOR PAN MENTION. FOR EXAMPLE
IN YOUNG CHILDREN WITH
SIGNIFICANT TO QUE STF TREATMENT
CAN BE USED IN LIEU OF COSTLY
AND STRESSFUL GENERAL ANESTHESIA
UNTIL THE CHILD IS OLD ENOUGH TO
SIT STILL FOR FILLINGS OR
NATURALLY LOSE THE BABY TEETH.
STF DOES TYPICALLY BECAUSE A
BLACK DISCOLORATION.
ON THE PART OF THE TOOTH IN
WHICH TWO K. IS ALREADY STARTED.
DESPITE THAT DENTISTS AND
FAMILIES FIND IT A USEFUL
TREATMENT OPTION FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES FRAIL ELDERLY
PATIENTS AND OTHER PATIENTS WERE
NOT ABLE TO COMPLY WITH THE
TRADITIONAL TREATMENT.
BECAUSE OF THIS THE BILL IS
LIMITED AND LIMITS THE SCOPE OF
BENEFITS TO THE THREE
POPULATIONS MENTIONED CHILDREN
SIX AND UNDER ADULTS WHO LIVE IN
SNIFFED OR LICENSED INTERMEDIATE
CARE FACILITIES.
AND PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES
WHERE TRADITIONAL RESTORATIVE
TREATMENT IS NOT OPTIMAL.
ADDITIONALLY IT REQUIRES
APPROPRIATE INFORMED CONSENT
WHICH NOTIFIES THE CARE GIVERS
ARE PARENTS ABOUT THE RISKS
BENEFITS AND OTHER POTENTIAL
TREATMENT OPTIONS.
SO THAT THE PARENTS OR THE CARE
GIVER AND THE DENTIST CAN MAKE.
THE BEST POSSIBLE DECISION
[inaudible]
THE PATIENT --
WE HAVE POLL DENTISTS ARE.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND THEY
TELL US THAT IT IS ALREADY BEING
INCORPORATED INTO A LARGE NUMBER
OF DENTAL PRACTICES ACROSS THE
STATE.
INCLUDING --
DOES WITH PRIVATE INSURANCE THE
VA COMMUNITY CLINICS AND CASH
PAY PATIENTS CITY BELIEVES THAT
STF SHOULD ALSO BE A TREATMENT
OPTION IN THE MEDICAL DENTAL
PROGRAM.
THIS LEGISLATION WILL ENSURE
THAT STF IS AN AVAILABLE OPTION
IN A DENTIST TO ABOUT WHEN
APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AT MEMBERS
MEGAN SUPERS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLUS ADVOCATES
REPRESENTING THE OVER THIRTEEN
HUNDRED COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS
IN CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
GLAD TO BE BACK WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
DO WE HAVE ANY.
PLEASE COME FORWARD [inaudible]
SEEING THEM.
COME COME BACK TO THE CENTER
MONEY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MR
AUTHOR THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD --
I'M SUPPORTIVE BUT I JUST TO
HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS
BECAUSE IT SOUNDS LIKE. ONE OF
THE INCENTIVES HERE'S THAT IT'S
LESS EXPENSIVE THAN A TREATMENT
THAT WOULD NOT HAVE THE CAUSE
MEDIC IMPACT IS THERE ANY
DISTINCTION MADE BY A TREATING
DENTIST FOR A CHILD IF IT.
TO BACK TO THROUGH HER FRONT
TOOTH IN TERMS OF THE COSMETIC
[inaudible]
IMPACT.
I KNOW THE BABY TEETH FALL OUT
BUT STILL FOR A THE KINDERGARTEN --
FIRST GRADER --
HE COULD TIAS STIGMATIZING --
TREATMENT SELECTION.
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ASKING
THAT QUESTION --
SO CERTAINLY WHEN THE CONCERNS
ABOUT THIS TREATMENT IS IS THAT
DOES CAUSE A DISCOLORATION TO
TOOTH CAUSES IT TO THAT THE DARK
IN COLOR WHERE IT'S APPLIED.
AND ONE THING I'D MAKE NOTE IS
MEANT AND THAT'S WHY WITH WE'VE
PARTICULARLY TARGETED --
THESE THREE POPULATIONS AND IN
INTERMS OF OFTENTIMES THESE ARE
PATIENTS WHERE.
DID PATIENT MAY NEED SEDATION OR
OTHER TYPES OF WHICH MAY BE NOT
AS READILY ACCESSIBLE AND SO
IDEALLY IF PATIENTS ABLE TO
TOLERATE AND RELEASE AS FULL WE
WOULD JUST GO AND DO THE FILLING
RIGHT AND GET AND GET IT DONE
RIGHT TAKE CARE TAKE CARE OF THE
DENTAL.
CARIES HOWEVER --
IN OUT IN THOSE OTHER CASES THE
ONE OF THE GOOD THINGS THAT THIS
TREATMENT ALSO DOES IT THE REST
THE FURTHER PROGRESSION SO WHAT
HAPPENS IF YOU HAVE A DENTAL
CARIES RIGHT.
AND IT'S AND YOU SAY WELL I
CAN'T TREAT IT NOW BECAUSE I
CAN'T PUT HIM UNDER SEDATION I
DON'T HAVE THE THE AND THEN WHAT
HAPPENS USING THIS TREATMENT
ACTUALLY ARRESTED FOR THE
PROGRESSIONS WHAT I SEE IS A
PEDIATRICIAN AS I HAVE A PATIENT
COMES AND WHO HAS A DENTAL.
CARIES AND THEN WILL HAPPEN IS
THAT BECAUSE WE CAN'T GET HIM
INTO THE OTHER FACILITY.
IT GETS WORSE AND WORSE AND I'LL
TELL YOU THAT BY THE WAY HOW WE
TALK ABOUT BABY TEETH YOUR ADULT
TEETH RIGHT BEHIND SO WHEN YOU
KNOW YOUR CHILD ISN'T A BABY
TEETH YOU KNOW THE DAHLE TEETH
COMING STREET.
RIGHT BEHIND AND ACTUALLY IF YOU
CAN'T THE CAT THE CAVITY OR
DENTAL CARIES WILL GO STRAIGHT
THROUGH THE BABY TEETH IT
ACTUALLY AFFECT THE ADULT TO
BEFORE EVEN POPS OUT.
SO THE FACT THAT WE WOULD HAVE
THIS IS AN OPTION TO HOPE THAT
PROGRESSION I THINK IT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THAT'S ONE
THE REASONS WHY I THINK THIS IS
SO IMPORTANT WE MAKE THIS A
COVERED ENTITY I APPRECIATE THE
CLARIFICATION I STILL THINK
THERE'S A BIT OF AN ECONOMIC --
DETERMINANT HERE I UNDERSTAND
SEDATION RAISES OTHER POTENTIAL
MEDICAL RISKS AND YOU GOTTA SEE
IF THE CHILD IS A GOOD CANDIDATE
FOR THAT IT SET TREATMENT --
IT SEEMS LIKE THIS COULD BE A
TWO TRACK SYSTEM THAT POOR KIDS
WILL BE.
AVAILED OF THIS OPTION IN THE
LONG TERM FOR THEIR DENTAL
HEALTH IS BETTER THAN NO
TREATMENT.
BUT DATA A CHILD OF MEANS COULD
[inaudible]
FORWARD.
THE OTHER TREATMENT I WOULD FIVE
POINT OUT AN OBVIOUS THE THAT
THIS LITTLE TRICKIER UNDER DODD
TEND TO CAL MANAGED CARE WHICH
IS IN SAN BOTH MY AREA WHICH IS.
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND ALL THE LA
COUNTY BUT THE REST IS ACT IF
YOU FOR SERVICE TO FOR THE
DENNIS ON THE GROUND.
THEY ACTUALLY MAKE MORE ACTUALLY
FILLING THE CAVITY THAN THEY
WOULD USING THIS TREATMENT SO
THAT INSTEAD OF DOESN'T QUITE
BUT I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING ABOUT FOR EXAMPLE IN A
MANAGED CARE SITUATIONS FOR
PAYMENT PER MONTH.
THEN YOU GO ON THE GO FOR THE
TRIP THE QUOTE YOU FOR TREATMENT
SO OF ICE BECAUSE I'M STILL
GETTING PAID A FIXED AMOUNT SO I
IT WE WE CAN CERTAINLY THINK
ABOUT HOW YOU WANT MY ADDRESS
THAT THANK YOU SHE DID THANK YOU.
SENATE MITCHELL.
THANK YOU SIR I WAS JUST TAKING
A LOOK AT THE LANGUAGE AND I SEE
THAT IT ONLY.
BY THE BENEFIT SHALL BE LIMITED
TO CHILDREN SIX YEARS OF AGE AND
UNDER SO IT'S VERY YOUNG KIDS
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES ARE
UNDERLYING CONDITIONS ADULTS WHO
LIVE IN SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES.
BECAUSE WHEN I HEARD YOU SAY
READILY ACCESSIBLE I WOULD BE
SURE OF READILY ACCESSIBLE MET
COVERAGE.
MATT UP ACCESS I WASN'T SURE IT
WAS READILY ACCESSIBLE.
BASED ON MY ABILITY TO WITHSTAND
THE AMNESIA OR IF IT WAS AN
ACCESS ISSUE.
WELL IT AND FOURTEEN MEDI CAL
AGAIN TO CAL IS AN ACCESS ISSUE
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT AND MANY
TIMES --
THAN TO HELP PATIENTS HAVE A
TREMENDOUSLY DIFFICULT TIME
GETTING A SEDATION YEAH --
TREATMENTS AND SO REALLY I THINK
THE TARGET POPULATION ARE THOSE
PATIENTS WHO --
BASICALLY EITHER ARE NOT ABLE TO
ARE EXTREMELY THE LATE TREES A
TIME BEFORE THEY CAN --
GET THAT --
ACCESS TO THE FACILITIES FOR
THAT FOR THE FULL TREATMENT AND
SO BE ABLE TO HAVE THIS
TREATMENT WILL AT LEAST HOLD THE
PROGRESSION OF THE DISEASE SO
DOESN'T GET EVEN WORSE --
WHILE WE'RE WAITING TO FINALLY
GET -- THE
US THE THE THE FINAL TREATMENT
GOT IT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU.
SENATE RUBIO.
AND KILL I HAD THE SAME CONCERNS
AS A MISTER MONEY I AND I HAD
ALREADY SHARED SOME OF THE
CONCERNS WITH YOU.
AS IT PERTAINS TO CHILDREN UNDER
SIX YEARS OF AGE I I DID ASK FOR
SOME PHOTOS AND I WAS ABLE TO TO
SEE WHAT THE AFFECTS ARE AND AND
THEY'RE PRETTY SEVERE THINKING
OF A CHILD THAT STARTS
KINDERGARTEN GOES TO FIRST GRADE
AND STOREHOUSES.
DISCOLORATION WHICH IS AGAIN IN
MY OPINION PRETTY SIGNIFICANT SO
I DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT
DENTISTRY BUT I WANTED TO JUST
GET A LITTLE BIT MORE FROM YOU.
I THOUGHT I HEARD YOU SAY MY
QUESTION WOULD HAVE BEEN AS
THERE MEMORY AS IT PERTAINS TO A
DECADE BEFORE THE TWO FALLS AND
THEN THE TWO K..
AFTER WHEN THE NEW ONE FALLS IN
I THOUGHT I JUST HEARD YOU SAY
THAT.
THAT IS.
THE ONE THAT'S COMING OUT IS
COMING RIGHT AFTER THAT
SOMETIMES THERE'S IMPACT TO THE
NEW TOOTH CRACKED YES IT WOULD
DOUBLE TO WHAT HAPPENS OF COURSE
THE DENTAL CARIES IS A CUT CALL
CAVITIES HOLE IN THE TOOTH RIGHT
TO THE BACK TO SPEEDING THROUGH
THE TOOTH.
AND IF YOU HAVE A BABY TWO SETS
HAS AN ADULT TO PUT WE'LL BE
RIGHT BEHIND IT IF IT ACTUALLY
EATS THROUGH FAR ENOUGH IT WILL
THEN START ON THE ADULT TO
SWITCH IS RIGHT.
BEHIND THE THE BABY TOOTH SO YOU
COULD ACTUALLY HAVE IF YOU DON'T
STOP THE KERRY SOME CONTINUING.
I CAN GO STRAIGHT INTO THE ADULT
TO STEPPED THAT DID THAT'S GOING
TO COME OUT --
MY OTHER QUESTION IS AND I KNOW
THAT --
EVENTUALLY THAT THEY WILL FALL
OUT BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THAT
STUFF WHAT HAPPENS BUT ANOTHER
QUESTION FOR ME IS IS THERE
ANOTHER WAY WERE MAYBE THEY CAN
PULL OUT THE TEETH IN THE REASON
I SAY THIS BECAUSE I WOULD HATE
TO SEE HIM.
CHILDREN THAT NEED IT THE ONES
THAT CAN AFFORD IT ALL WALKING
AND NOT ALL BUT WALKING AROUND
WITH DISCOLORED TEETH AND THEN
THE ONES ARE MORE AFFLUENT THAT
COULD AFFORD A WALKING AROUND
WITH.
BETTER TEETH IT JUST YOU KNOW
SEEMS TO ME THAT YOU START THAT
THE DIVISION IN TERMS OF EQUITY
IN ECONOMICS --
I JUST WANT TO KNOW THERE'S ANY
OTHER OPTIONS FOR THAT LIKE
PULLING OUT A TEETH IS IN THERE
AN EASIER WAY FOR A CHILD.
I'M NOT A DENTIST SO I JUST KIND
OF WANT.
TO GET OUT ON THE MARKET SO
THERE ARE --
FIRST IF THE THE TWO THIEVES
STAINED BLACK WITH STF THERE ARE --
METHODS AFTER THE TOOTH IS
STABILIZED --
TO GO IN AND PUT IN A WHITE
FILLING OR PUT ON A VENEER --
SO THAT WE'VE STOPPED FIX THE
COLORATION UNTIL THE BABY TO
FALLS OUT --%
IN TERMS OF OTHER OPTIONS.
A LOT OF KIDS WITH SIGNIFICANT
DECAY AND UP WITH SILVER CAPS ON
THEIR BABY TEETH OR YOU KNOW YOU
HAVE TO GO IN AND DO SOME SOME.
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT DENTISTRY TO
PUT CAPS ON AND SO THE PARENT
MIGHT DECIDE.
MAKE THE DECISION WITH THE
DENTIST I'D RATHER AND AND WE
SEE THIS A LOT.
REGARDLESS OF ECONOMIC STATUS
THE PARENTS AND THE DENTIST
HAVING A CONVERSATION AND SAYING
YOU KNOW WHAT I'D RATHER HAVE A
BLACK STAY IN THAN HAVE --
THAT HAVE TO HAVE THEM YOU KNOW
UNDERGO --
SIGNIFICANT DENTISTRY OR UNDERGO
ANESTHESIA AND ON TOP OF THAT
YOU YOU WOULD DEFINITELY NOT
WANT TO PULL OUT A TOOTH THAT
COULD BE STABILIZED OTHERWISE
BECAUSE THEN.
THE TEETH MOVE OR THE IT DAMAGES
THE BONE SO --
YOU ALWAYS WANT TO TRY TO
STABILIZE THE TWO FIRST BEFORE
YOU WITH THE LAST.
DITCH EFFORT WOULD BE TO PULL IT
OUT.
OKAY SO SEE FASTER MY QUESTION
HE'S STILL A LITTLE BIT
CONCERNED ONLY BECAUSE I SAW TO
ME THE SEVERITY OF THAT THE
DISCOLORATION BUT BUT I YOU KNOW
ACT.
GOING BACK TO WHAT YOU SAID
ABOUT HIM.
AND NOW MORE SOMETHING TO TO
MINIMIZE THE THE STAIN I MEAN
THEY'RE STILL COST ATTACHED TO
ITSELF.
MY OPINION MORE OFTEN THAN NOT
PARENTS WERE NOT TO HAVE
SOMETHING COVER THE STING BUT
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR FOR
SURE IN AYE AYE I HAD A LITTLE
BIT OF CONCERN BUT I I DO
UNDERSTAND THAT WE WANT TO SAY
FUTURE TEETH AND MAKE SURE THAT.
THEY'RE ALSO NOT WALKING AROUND
WITH SILVER DETAILED SO THANK
YOU FOR THAT PRECIADO.
SENATOR MONEY.
THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE THE
CHANCE TO JUST ASK ONE MORE
QUERY.
SO WHEN YOU SEE TO THE CAN
CHILDREN THIS YOUNG.
IS THERE A CORRELATION WITH
CONSUMPTION OF SUGAR SWEETENED
BEVERAGES IF YOU KNOW DOCTOR PAN
OR YOUR WITNESS.
SO ACTUALLY --
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT CAN LEAD
TO TOOTH DECAY AND CHILDREN --
IS FOR EXAMPLE CONTINUED BOTTLE
USE ARE GOING TO BED WITH THAT
AND CERTAINLY --
IF IN THAT BOTTLE IS OUR SUGAR
SWEETENED BEVERAGES INCLUDING
FRUIT JUICES --
HOPEFULLY NOT SODA BUT THEN THAT
WOULD MAKE IT EVEN WORSE YES SO
IT DOES OFTEN ACOSTA QUICKLY
FRONTAL DO THINK A IS --
WE AND CHOIR OF THE PARENT THAT%
THERE THE CHILD IS FREE GOING
GOING AROUND LET'S USUALLY A
BOTTLE IN YOUR MOUTH OR GOING TO
BED WITH A VIOLENT MOUTH AUSTIN
FILLED WITH --
SUGAR SWEETENED BEVERAGE OF SOME
SAMPLE SOMETIMES PEOPLE THINK
IT'S A HELPFUL RIGHT USE LIKE A
REFUSAL TO ADDED SUGAR IN IN IT
IS KNOWN.
SOME FAMILIES TO PUT THE SUGAR
SWEETENED BEVERAGE IN THE BOTTLE
INCLUDING SERVICE YES
UNFORTUNATELY THAT THAT IS TRUE
I I SAY RELUCTANTLY I'D HATE TO
AGREED THAT THAT BUT YES THAT
DOES HAPPEN YES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS.
CNN CENTER MANAGER CALLS OUT
WELL I I I UNDERSIDE FOR SO I'M
I THINK.
THE MEMBERS COMMITTEE FOR
SHARING YOUR CONCERNS --
AND BUT I THINK THAT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT OPTION TO BE AVAILABLE
IT'S ONE THAT IS PROVEN TO BE
EFFICACIOUS IT'S NOT JUST WOULD
NOT DOING THIS JUST BECAUSE IT'S
CHEAPER WE ACTUALLY THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT --
I THINK OPTION --
FOR DENNIS TO BE ABLE TO
ACTUALLY --
PREVENT FURTHER ENDS OF THEIR TO
THE OF THE CHURCH OF A PATIENT'S
TOOTH DECAY AND ALLOW THEM TO
ACTUALLY PRESERVE ACTUALLY MORE
OF THEIR TEETH UNTIL WE CAN GET --
THEM ACCESS TO FINAL.
TWO MORE COMPREHENSIVE TREATMENT
AND EXPECT THE ASPIRIN.
THANK YOU THAT DOCTOR FOUND --
THIS IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS ON LOOKING FOR
MOTION.
MOVED BY SENATOR.
AND WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR ALSO MADE THE MOTION.
RIGHT PAN HI CAN I STONE STONE I
DORADO.
DORADO I GROWTH [inaudible]
HER TADO.
CA.GOV I LEYVA LEYVA AYE
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING MONNING I
RUBIO [inaudible]
I OKAY.
SO IT'S IT'S OUT EIGHT ZERO
THAT'S OUT OKAY --
NOT OUT YET WE I THINK WE SPOKE
BUT THIS OKAY.
WELL THANK YOU I DON'T KNOW IF
IT'S MY FUTURE WITH.
EXTRA MUCH.
OKAY SO THE NEXT ITEM ON THE
AGENDA AXES ARE CONSENT CALENDAR
WE HAVE TWO ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR --
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB SIXTY SIX BY
CENTER ATKINS AND NUMBER THREE
SB ONE TWENTY NINE BY MYSELF
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY --
CENTER MITCHELL --
SIX THREE CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THE CONSENT CAL I STONE.
STONE I'D DORADO.
DRESSEL AYE GROVE HER TADO I FOR
TITLE I LEYVA.
LEYVA I AM MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING MONNING I
RUBIO HI RUBIO I OKAY SO THE
CONSENT TELLERS OUT.
EIGHT ZERO OKAY SO WITH THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK AND CALL
THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS --
SO.
AND SIX TO YOU READY YET.
OKAY SO WHERE WE'RE GONNA START
WITH -- ITEM
NUMBER ONE SB TWENTY NINE BY
CENTER DORADO TOOK THREE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
STONE.
STONE NO.
GROWTH.
MONNING MONNING I THAT BILLS OUT
SEVEN ONE THANK YOU --
NEXT ITEM SO WE'VE WRAPPED UP
FOR SO NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER
SIX SB THREE OH ONE OF MY CENTER
LEYVA.
A SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
OF ABSENT MEMBERS.
STONE.
STONE I GROWTH [inaudible]
HE THAT BILL IS OUT EIGHT ZERO
FINALLY ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AS
CHAIR FOR BY CENTER LEYVA --
SIXTY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF
ABSENT MEMBERS STONE.
STONE IS NO GROW. SEVEN THAT
BILLS OUT.
SEVEN ONE EVERYTHING IS --
ON BUT COULD I CLOSE ROOMS OKAY.
OKAY SO LET'S CALL THE SO
ACTUALLY.
RIGHT BECAUSE I THINK A CLOSE
RUN RULES TO IMPROVE THE RULES
OKAY SET THE RULES THAT JUST
CLARIFIED THE RULES WE ACTUALLY
JUST WHEN AND IMPROVE TWIN.
BECAUSE THAT WAY WITH THE RULES
IN PLACE FOR THE HEARING SO SO
WE'RE DONE WITH THAT SO WITH
THAT -- THE
AGENDA IS CONCLUDED AND THIS
HEARING OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON HEALTH IS NOW IT [inaudible]
YEAH.
YEAH YOU'RE ON EVERYTHING YEAH.
RIGHT THE FRAZIER AND MEETING BE
SURE.
JOHN OKAY.
GOOD OKAY SO WITH THAT --
THIS HEARING OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH IS NOW
ADJOURNED THANK YOU